Hey everybody, we are here with a new episode of programming throwdown and it's patrick and i talking about working from home um but before that we're going to jump into a little bit of intro topic uh for people this is their first time listening uh you have some news news and links of the day book of the show tool the show, and then we will dive into our main juicy topic, which is working from home. And it's going to be interesting because this is one of the few topics where Patrick and I disagree. So we're going to have a little bit of a friendly debate here about working from home. But before we go into that, I want to talk about smart homes. I remember hearing about smart homes a really long time ago
大家好，欢迎收听新一期的《编程抛头露面》（Programming Throwdown）。今天我和帕特里克（Patrick）要聊聊居家办公的话题。但在那之前，我们要先进行一些开场环节。对于第一次收听的朋友，我们会有每日新闻和链接、本期推荐书籍、本期推荐工具，然后才会进入我们今天的主题——居家办公。这会很有意思，因为这是我和帕特里克意见不合的少数话题之一。所以我们会在节目中进行一场友好的辩论。但在进入正题前，我想先聊聊智能家居。我记得很久以前就听说过智能家居。
and thinking, actually, here's where I first heard it. Remember when Bill Gates, this is like, I think in the 90s, he showed off his home and as he was walking through the house, the lights are turning on, the sound was following him. Yeah, I remember thinking that was amazing. This is what a billionaire does. Actually, I had one before that. It was Carousel of Progress and then that. Oh, man, Carousel of Progress is so good. So just for people who don't know, Carousel of Progress is this amazing ride at Disney.
当时我想，其实我第一次听到这个概念是在这儿。还记得比尔·盖茨吗？大概是在90年代，他展示了他的家。当他在屋里走动时，灯光会自动亮起，音乐也会跟着他走。是的，我记得当时觉得这太神奇了，这就是亿万富翁的生活。其实在那之前我见过一个类似的，就是迪士尼的“进步之轮”（Carousel of Progress）。哦，天哪，“进步之轮”太棒了。给不知道的朋友介绍一下，“进步之轮”是迪士尼一个非常棒的游乐项目。
It's still around. I took my name there. Amazing is a bit of an oversell. But yes, it is a ride at Disney World. Yeah, I guess it's dated now. It's like in the future we will have microwaves you know um but at the time it blew my mind and they um uh you know they go through the progress of of like the american story and stuff it's really cool um at the very end uh
它现在还在。我带我名字去过那里。说“神奇”有点夸张了，但它确实是迪士尼乐园里的一个游乐项目。是的，我想它现在已经过时了。它就像是在说“未来我们将拥有微波炉”之类的，但在当时它确实让我大开眼界。他们讲述了美国故事的进步历程，真的很酷。在最后……
they talk about the future which is now the past which is kind of funny to think about but but in the future we'll have an oculus quest effectively and um and they had a uh smart uh was a smart oven yes correct um and then the guy uh the the you know the the father of the show he he um he says something about like the sun is 900 degrees or something and it causes the oven. What was that? The score. He's like getting his score. He's like, I've got 800. I've got 900.
他们谈论的未来现在已经变成了过去，想起来挺有趣的。但在当时，他们说未来会有类似Oculus Quest的东西，还有智能烤箱。是的，没错。然后那个角色，就是那个父亲，他说太阳有900度还是什么的，导致烤箱……那是什么？分数。他好像在看他的分数，说“我得了800分，我得了900分”。
Oh, yeah. That's right. And the oven thinks he's setting the temperature and burns the turkey. It's hilarious. But yeah, you're right. I remember seeing that and thinking there's no way an oven would be able to understand what you're saying and and here we are um then i went through a phase where i thought you know the problem is that it's too expensive to retrofit a home and so like you're never actually gonna really see any of these things um which i think was true for a long time. But now,
哦，对，没错。然后烤箱以为他在设置温度，结果把火鸡烤焦了。太搞笑了。但你是对的，我记得当时看到那个场景时想，烤箱怎么可能听得懂你在说什么呢？而现在我们做到了。后来我经历了一个阶段，觉得问题在于改造房屋的成本太高了，所以你永远不会真正看到这些东西普及。我觉得这在很长一段时间里确实是真的。但现在，
you know, people are buying new homes and the technology has been around for a while. And so I'm actually starting to see more like smart things in homes, which is really cool. I personally went through and redid all the switches in the house to go through uh alexa so now i can tell alexa to uh you know turn off the lights in this room or turn on lights in that room and i have them on a schedule so you know when the kids forget to turn the lights off in the morning it turns all the room lights off every weekday morning um and it's been pretty awesome and it's been actually pretty easy to set up yeah i actually don't think homes are becoming more smart i think actually a lot of this stuff is uh figuring out how to retrofit them it seems to be anyways but i kind of like that it's kind of like smart tvs i kind
人们在买新房，这项技术也存在一段时间了。所以我开始看到家里有更多智能设备，这真的很酷。我个人把家里所有的开关都换成了支持Alexa的，所以我现在可以告诉Alexa关掉这个房间的灯，或者打开那个房间的灯。我还设置了定时，这样孩子们早上忘了关灯时，它会在每个工作日的早晨自动关掉所有房间的灯。这真的很棒，而且设置起来其实相当简单。是的，其实我不觉得房子变得更智能了，我觉得大部分工作其实是在研究如何改造它们。看起来确实是这样，但我有点喜欢这种感觉，就像智能电视一样。
of have a beef i hate smart tvs because i hate my really nice tv okay great so i like the tv but the smart part i don't know i don't want to see ads when i start my tv that's not only that it's like two three years old and then it's laggy is i'll get out and they force you into the like there's no hardwire base os that will just like let you switch to whatever you've plugged into hdmi and so it ruins the modularity and all of a sudden your nice expensive tv feels junky which probably intent somewhat intentional but um the smart home stuff i guess can be on a very big spectrum from like frustrating to amazing i also uh retrofit a lot of my lights i
我有点意见，我讨厌智能电视，因为我讨厌我那台很好的电视。好吧，我很喜欢这台电视，但“智能”部分……我不知道，我不想在启动电视时看到广告。不仅如此，它才用了两三年就变得卡顿得要命，而且他们强迫你使用系统。没有那种纯粹的硬件基础操作系统，让你直接切换到HDMI接口，这破坏了模块化。突然间，你那台昂贵的好电视就感觉像垃圾了，这可能在某种程度上是故意的。但智能家居的东西，我觉得范围很广，从令人沮丧到令人惊叹都有。我也改造了很多灯光，
did it with kind of a hard hard mode so i did it with Lutron Radio Raw which is you actually go into the electrical box open it up rewire in the switches and sort of switch them all over and it adds dimming capability but you there's like some features locked behind like a training class you have to go to them and get or whatever
我用的是一种比较硬核的方式，我用了Lutron RadioRA。你得进入配电箱，打开它，重新接线，把开关都换掉。它增加了调光功能，但有些功能被锁定在培训课程之后，你必须去参加培训才能解锁。
so I had to do some kind of like workarounds to and I bought all my switches used on eBay because there are like physical actual switches rather than buttons so they're like really nice and they color match to all the other light switches in the house so I made it yeah I have I have the
所以我不得不做了一些变通，而且我所有的开关都是在eBay上买的二手货，因为它们是真正的物理开关，而不是按钮，所以手感非常好，而且颜色和家里其他的灯光开关匹配。所以我做到了，我有……
same thing except I got the Amazon basics version which connects to Alexa and all that but it's the same in the sense that you have to pull out physically pull out the switch and it replaces it with as you said a button yeah so this one has still an actual switch uh and it will work if the internet you know it doesn't connect over wi-fi so it has its own like backhaul radio network you know like whatever um and then you have like a hub in the house and then the hub bridges into ethernet so that you know you can expose it in in my case siri and google home and whatever
同样的东西，除了我买的是亚马逊基础版（Amazon Basics），它能连接Alexa等等。但道理是一样的，你必须物理拆下开关，换成你说的按钮。是的，我这个还是真正的开关，而且如果断网了它也能用，因为它不是通过Wi-Fi连接的，它有自己的回程无线网络。家里有一个集线器，然后集线器通过以太网连接，这样你就可以在我的情况下，通过Siri、Google Home或其他方式来控制它。
um for for that optionality but same thing you know setting schedules and you know connecting various things fans and whatever yeah none of us neither of us have done i'm assuming you haven't done like a smart fridge or a smart stove or anything like that no i've seen a i've seen an amazing stove um where you set instead of setting how much heat you want you set the temperature so you're like i want this base plate to be 350 degrees and apparently if you get it to the right temperature then you don't need cooking oil like you could throw an egg on and if it's the right temperature it'll like caramelize the outside and the egg will just slide around oh that's cool i i don't know but i've seen the ones where you
为了那种可选性，但道理一样，设置定时，连接各种风扇之类的。是的，我们俩都没做过，我假设你没用过智能冰箱或智能炉灶之类的吧？没有，我见过一个很棒的炉灶，你设置的不是火力大小，而是温度。比如你想要底盘达到350度，显然如果你能达到准确的温度，就不需要食用油了。你可以把鸡蛋打上去，如果温度合适，它会把外层焦糖化，鸡蛋就会滑来滑去。哦，那很酷。我不知道，但我见过那种……
know you tell it like what kind of meat it is and approximately you know how much it weighs and you stick a temperature probe you know kind of on the inside and it's measuring basically the temperature gradient like it knows the outside temperature with the temperature probe and then it knows like the internal temperature. And so it's trying to, you know, kind of intelligently guide. It sounds cool, but I just don't know. Like I normally keep toasters in ovens for more than a decade. I don't know, like in a decade, is that going to age well or not yeah my uh my parents have one of those they have like a ninja and uh it's actually amazing like neither of my parents uh i hope you're not listening mom are pretty good cooks to be honest um but this thing is like you can't mess it up like you basically take a raw steak you put it in you put the probe in you press a button
你知道，你告诉它是什么肉，大概有多重，然后插上温度探针，它基本上是在测量温度梯度。它通过探针知道外部温度，然后知道内部温度。所以它试图智能地引导你。听起来很酷，但我不知道。我通常烤面包机和烤箱一用就是十年以上。我不知道十年后这东西还能不能用。是的，我父母有一个那种Ninja牌的，其实真的很棒。我父母都不是什么好厨师，希望我妈没在听。但这东西你根本搞砸不了，你把生牛排放进去，插上探针，按个按钮，
and then like a perfectly cooked steak comes out and uh even they can do it so i've been really impressed so nice but i have seen people on the internet with you know home assistant setups and stuff that uh have insane scripts and all i can think of is like what happens if something were to happen to me and i end up in the hospital or whatever and i'm not home and like my spouse my wife like you know she can't figure out how to like debug the fact that like the light switches aren't working or you know air conditioning keeps going to random temperatures and so I do actually think there's like a sweet spot in what parts you want to be just a little bit better than a dumb thing can do but actually you can go overboard with you know rfid tags and scanning in and a whole procedure that could just like be very fragile and i i would shy away from any i've
然后就能做出完美的牛排，连他们都能做到，所以我印象非常深刻。很好，但我见过网上有人用Home Assistant搭建系统，脚本写得疯狂。我唯一能想到的是，如果我出了什么事进了医院，或者我不在家，我妻子根本不知道怎么调试那些不工作的灯光开关，或者空调一直乱跳温度。所以我确实认为，在“比笨设备好一点”和“过度设计”之间有一个平衡点。你可以用RFID标签和扫描系统搞得太复杂，结果变得非常脆弱。我个人避开了所有这些。
not embraced any of those things myself yeah the other thing which is kind of adjacent to smart home is uh i have like these smart tags on all of our keys and so every uh every three months i have a little calendar notification for myself that's like charge all the tags and they're all they all take like a little micro usb and i actually bought a hub that has like an octopus uh of of micro usb flanges that come out and i plug in all the keys into them to recharge little tags but that's been a life changer because like some so many times like oh i can't find the keys it's like hang on you know it's like you're captain america you press the button it's like you're captain america you feel like a hero at home all right i should be i should be an
我没尝试过那些东西。是的，还有一件事和智能家居相关，我在所有的钥匙上都挂了智能标签。每三个月我都会在日历上提醒自己给标签充电。它们都用微型USB接口，我甚至买了一个集线器，上面有八爪鱼一样的微型USB线，我把所有钥匙都插上去充电。这改变了我的生活，因为以前经常找不到钥匙。现在就像你是美国队长，按个按钮，感觉自己像个英雄。好吧，我应该成为……
advertisement for uh etex but yeah i will say i'm the one who has to go on to all the apps and ping various devices to get you know help help finding stuff but i remember growing up that was always a thing i can't find this i can't find that you can't find the remote okay all right jumping on to news you have the first news yeah i wanted to cover this somebody pointed out to me the other day your conversation got to to rocket launches in space and they're like patrick you're the one who always seems to know all of these things when's this happening whatever i was like okay well i feel attacked but you're not wrong um anyway so so i feel like we had to cover it uh on here which was since last recording which
E-tags的广告代言人。但确实，我得负责在所有App上ping各种设备来找东西。我记得小时候总是这样，“我找不到这个，找不到那个，你找不到遥控器”。好吧，进入新闻环节，你先来？是的，我想聊聊这个。前几天有人指出，我们的谈话涉及到了火箭发射和太空，他们说：“帕特里克，你好像总是知道这些事，这到底什么时候发生的？”我说：“好吧，我觉得被冒犯了，但你没说错。”总之，我觉得我们必须在节目里聊聊，因为自上次录音以来……
has been a while uh spacex had their uh ift5 launch where they sent a spaceship and the and the booster up and landed the booster back caught it on chopsticks at the spacex headquarters there in uh in texas and then the the starship went all the way almost all the way around the world they went to the indian ocean and splashed down and they actually caught it on a buoy camera. It was very cool. If you haven't seen it by now, I guess you're probably hiding from the news.
已经过去很久了。SpaceX进行了IFT-5发射，他们把飞船和助推器送上去，然后把助推器接了回来，在德克萨斯州的SpaceX总部用“筷子”抓住了它。然后星舰绕地球飞了几乎一整圈，飞到了印度洋并溅落。他们甚至用浮标摄像头拍到了它。非常酷。如果你到现在还没看过，那你大概是在躲避新闻。
Um, but like definitely go watch it is very cool. And I just wanted to, you know, talk about that. That is a huge engineering fee. Like, you know,
但一定要去看，非常酷。我只是想聊聊这个，这是一项巨大的工程壮举。
just in general, like all of it, people didn't know this, like cost to orbit. I still think, I know, I think I've said this before probably on this show, but you know told people there's a few things i think will just like completely transform stuff in a way we don't understand and i think really really low cost like per mass to
总的来说，人们可能不知道，进入轨道的成本……我可能之前在节目里说过，但我认为有几件事会彻底改变一切，以我们无法理解的方式。我认为极低的单位质量进入轨道成本就是其中之一，因为你可以把很多东西送上去，制造系统等等，你可以开始开采小行星。我觉得很难预测如果进入太空变得廉价且频繁，会发生什么。这只是我的个人观点。甚至从星链（Starlink）就能看到这一点，美国发生了一些自然灾害，比如飓风，人们能快速获得网络，请求援助，这简直是变革性的。现在他们甚至开启了手机直连卫星通话功能。所以我觉得未来一切都会默认拥有持续的网络连接。
orbit is one of them because you can put lots of things up manufacturing systems whatever you can like start to harvest asteroids i just think like it's very hard to predict all of the things that can happen if it's cheap and frequent access to to space um just my personal opinion even starting to see that with starlink and like there was some natural disasters some hurricanes here in the united states and people getting internet fast and you know being able to request assistance and that kind of stuff is is just you know transformational and now even they were turning on cell phone to satellite direct communication for calls um so there's just all sorts of things i think we're not we're going to be in a future where there's just constant internet connectivity for everything as a given
这只是低门槛带来的变革，但正如我提到的，还有其他事情……充足的能源，几乎无限的能源，是另一件我认为人们低估了其变革性的事情。顺便说一下，关于开采小行星，我有个问题。因为我玩过《X4》和《Everspace》，玩过很多在太空中开采小行星的游戏。我一直想知道，这是真的吗？小行星真的有稀有金属吗？足以证明去开采它们的成本是合理的吗？稀有金属在地球上很稀有，以一种廉价且充足的方式获取……所以这不是……
is just like the low barrier and that's already pretty transformational but then also you know just like i mentioned you know all the other things that that kind of come on um abundant power like almost infinite power would be another one that i think people underestimate how transformational it'll be just while we're on this topic anyways but going back i had a question about the harvesting asteroids because i've played like x4 and ever space i've played a lot of video games where you are harvesting asteroids in space and i always wondered like is that a real thing like do asteroids have rare metals like to so they have enough rare metals to justify going and harvesting them so rare metal is like rare on earth in a cheap and abundant you know like way to access so it's not it's not a thing
今天会发生的事。我觉得人们尝试过让它实现，因为它正处于负担得起的边缘。这就像是那种你可以尝试成为先行者的事情，总有人会是第一个。但同样真实的是，在50年后的某一天，这会变得理所当然。比如，把推进剂送上去，然后用推进剂去小行星带，找个小行星，带回来。我不认为这会像美国西部的淘金热那样，我觉得会是人们定位一颗小行星并把它带回来。但想象一下，如果黄金从一种相对稀有的东西，
that would happen today and i think people have tried to make it happen because like it's on the verge of affordability that's one of those things like you can try to be an early person and someone will be the first but it's also true that in whatever 50 years it'll just be a no-brainer right like hey to go out to that you can get propellant up and then use that propellant to go out to the asteroid belt get an asteroid look for an asteroid whatever bring it back it's not going to be like humans of the old west you know like going out and panning for gold kind of stuff i don't think and it'll be people locating one bringing it but imagine if gold went from like a relatively rare thing
变得比……也许不是像铁那么便宜，但比普通金属便宜。你会把小行星扔进湖里吗？你会定位它吗？也许吧。但我的意思是，如果推进剂——因为推进剂又重又大，是个问题——如果你能把它送上去，拿到小行星，
to cheaper than, you know, maybe not like iron, but cheaper than, you know, just normal metals or whatever. And so you would drop the asteroid in like a lake or something? Like you would position it? Maybe. But no, I mean, I think if propellant, which is a problem because it's heavy and bulky, if you could get it up, get the asteroid,
把它带回地球轨道，或者用设备开采并提炼到一定程度，然后用胶囊把它带回来。不是整个小行星，而是黄金。我的意思是，想象一下……
bring it back to Earth orbit or mine it with things and sort of refine it to some degree, and then you would bring it back just in a capsule or whatever. Not the whole asteroid, but the gold. I mean, we bring back, imagine like what, you know,
四个宇航员在龙飞船里安全返回。想象一下，如果胶囊里装的不是人，而是沉甸甸的黄金。那是很多黄金。为什么不能直接把黄金扔进湖里？因为在穿过大气层时它不会烧毁，对吧？哦，是的，它会变成等离子体，然后你会得到散布在地球各处的离解黄金。哦，我没意识到……我以为……
you four humans in a dragon capsule come back down safely. Imagine if the capsule was instead, I mean, really heavy, filled with gold. That's gold. That's a lot of gold why can't you just drop the gold in a lake because i mean it won't burn in the atmosphere right i mean oh yeah well it'll turn into plasma and then you'll have like disassociated uh gold spread all over the earth oh i didn't realize uh i didn't i thought the
黄金的熔点比那高得多。其实很低。是的，几乎任何东西……我们经常被岩石撞击，所以你会损失很多。所以我不知道，也许有人有办法做到，或者以某种非常受控的方式进入。等等，这可能是一个愚蠢的问题，但如果黄金会损毁，那飞船进入大气层时为什么不会损毁？是有比黄金更强的东西吗？这不是一个单一维度的问题。哦，我明白了。是的，黄金本身确实不强。但大部分热量是通过剥离来散发的。
melting temperature of gold was like a lot higher than that it's really low yeah i mean almost anything like you know we get hit by rock rocks all the time and you so you lose a lot of it so i i don't know maybe some people have some ideas on doing that or if you very controlled the entry somehow wait so maybe okay is it kind of a dumb question but like if if gold destroys and like how does the spaceship not destroy when it comes in the atmosphere like is this something stronger than gold that's uh not a single dimensional question right like oh i see yeah i mean gold is not a very strong thing period um but uh yeah i, the bulk of it is by shedding, shedding heat.
所以最常见的就是使用陶瓷瓦。它们在某种程度上是烧蚀性的。外层非常隔热，所以热量不会传导进去，陶瓷本身能承受极高的温度。而且我相信他们也利用了部分材料燃烧的过程，这种燃烧外层的反应实际上冷却了下面的材料。哦，很有趣。这非常精细。但对于金属来说，你做不到这一点，对吧？金属导热性太强了，如果你烧外层，
So you get these ceramic tiles is the most common thing. And they're, I guess, somewhat ablative. So like the parts on the outside, they're very insulative. So the heat doesn't pass in ceramics themselves have a very, very high temperature. And then I believe they also use some forms of like parts of it is, is burning away. But that reaction of burning the outside away is actually cooling the stuff underneath uh oh interesting it's very careful but for a metal you don't get that right metals are very conductive so if you burn something on the outside it would
所有的热量都会传导进来。它们是超导热的。所以理论上，你可以用陶瓷板包围一大块黄金，或者把它放进胶囊里，然后着陆。是的，这说得通。这太酷了。所以我们拭目以待。我认为这也是……通过推进剂控制速度。我不是说五年内就能实现，但我认为看到有人几乎以指数级速度改善我们进入太空的能力，非常酷。向可能正在收听并感到尴尬的SpaceX员工致敬。SpaceX的人现在可能讨厌我们。我有几个朋友在那里，他们工作极其努力，非常敬业。
just all that all the heat would just come through it they're hyperconductive so like you could in theory like like surround a huge chunk of gold in space with like ceramic plates and then throw it like build a capsule around the gold or put it in a capsule and yeah land yeah okay that makes sense that is super cool man so we'll see um you know and i think that's also uh you know controlling the speed using propellants i'm not saying that's going to be five years i'm just like you know it's it's very cool to see somebody you know almost exponentially improving our access to to space so shout out to any spacex people who may be listening to this and like cringing i do feel free maybe we'll have oh yeah spacex people hate us right now i have a few friends there and uh yeah they work uh incredibly hard so they're very
向他们致敬。接下来是测试6号，在录音后的几周内进行，所以你们听到这期节目时可能已经完成了。他们会尝试做同样的事情，但做得更好。积累经验，学习，测量，改进传感器，尝试一些小的修改。非常酷，非常令人兴奋。我提到的很多人错过的一点是，用“筷子”把助推器接回发射台，最终甚至把星舰也接回来，这意味着你可以把它放回原处，加满燃料，再次发射。整个过程不需要溅落或在无人船上着陆，也不需要费力运输。
dedicated and yeah huge props to them um and so upcoming will be the test number i guess are numbering at six so in the next couple weeks as of recording so it may be already done by by the time you guys listen to this episode but they're gonna kind of attempt to do most of the same things but you know just a little bit better um and so build up you know repetitions and learn and you know measure better sensors try try some you know small modifications but but definitely very cool very exciting um and then the thing that i mentioned to people that i guess a lot of folks missed was landing the booster back on the pad with you know the chopsticks and eventually even the starship back uh means you can basically set it back down fill it back up again and shoot it up like this whole thing where you don't splash it down or land it on a drone ship or a you know landing pad and have to like ferry it
这意味着你真的可以……这就是计划，把它们放回发射台，加满燃料，检查一下没坏，然后再次发射。所以你可以一天之内多次发射同一艘飞船。如果有一打飞船，每天发射两次，那就是每天24次太空飞行。想想你能送上去多少东西，这太疯狂了。是的，太疯狂了。非常酷。有很多话想说，但为了节省时间，如果还没看过视频，一定要去看。我看了，真的很棒。向那些人致敬。好了，我的第一条新闻是ShareDB。这是一个非常酷的库，用于各种项目。基本前提是……也许我先用Git做类比。在Git中，你有提交（commit），先不考虑分支，你可以做一个提交。然后如果我去向主分支提交，它会说“不行，你不是最新版本，你需要快进（fast-forward）”。所以你执行git pull，它会尝试……如果有人在你工作时做了修改，它会尝试撤销你的修改，应用他们的修改，然后再重新应用你的修改。大多数情况下这很有效，除非发生冲突。比如你删了一行，我给同一行加了字符，现在就有了冲突，因为我在修改你删除的东西。
means you literally just like that and that is the plan they just like lower it back down onto it is the launch pad just lower it back down on the launch pad pump it with propellant again check to make sure nothing's broken and send it up so you can sort of send a single ship up multiple times a day um at sort of like production and so with a dozen ships doing you know even two launches a day that's 24 flights to space a day think about how much stuff you could put up like it's crazy yeah that's wild um super cool man um yeah i mean there's so many things i could go there but we'll just in interest of time check out the video if you haven't seen it i've seen it it's it's really amazing um and uh yeah huge props to those folks um all right my news first news is share db there's a really cool library of uses for a
所以不清楚该怎么做，也许应该取消删除，或者我的修改现在无关紧要了。Git会警告你，说“嘿，有冲突”，然后你去代码编辑器里修复它。这些大家都知道。但你可以想象一个自主的、基于规则的系统。比如我刚才举的例子，你可以说“如果发生冲突，一个人删了一行，另一个人修改了它，那就直接删掉那一行”。所以你可以定义规则来管理这些冲突，无需人工干预。虽然结果可能不是你想要的，但它不需要人工介入。这就是“操作转换”（Operational Transform）的前提，它本质上是一套规则，让你永远不会陷入不知道该怎么办的状态。所以Google Docs，任何协作工具，如果你用过Notion或其他工具，它们都基于这个前提。如果我和帕特里克正在一起编辑一个Google文档，就像我们现在这样，帕特里克在我修改的同时删了一行，Google文档不会弹出来说“有合并冲突”，它有逻辑来处理它。我记不清具体怎么处理的了，
variety of projects and the basic premise is um maybe i'll just start with git as an analogy right so you know with git you have uh commits and like you could make a commit uh don't consider yourself yet with branches just for a moment but like you could make a commit and then if i go to make a commit uh to main it will say oh you can't do that because you're not on the latest version you need to fast forward and so you do a git pull and so it will try to you know if someone's made changes while i was working it'll try to like you know undo my changes make their changes and then redo my changes um and most of the time that works except it could be a conflict like if if you uh deleted a line and i added some characters to that same line that's now deleted now we have a conflict right because you know i'm
可能就是删掉那一行，但它会处理好。正如你所想，处理这些并不简单，有很多奇怪的边缘情况需要考虑。所以ShareDB这个库实际上是由开发Google Docs协作功能的那个人制作的。背景是，这个人构建了这种让人们在浏览器中使用操作转换进行协作的方式。Google收购了他的公司，变成了Google Wave，在我看来那个产品管理得很糟糕，随后失败了。但后来Google Wave被Google Docs吸收，做出了我认为非常棒的产品，
modifying something that you deleted and so it's not obvious what we should do there like maybe it should be undeleted or maybe my modifications are now irrelevant right it's not clear and so git will warn you i'll say hey we have a conflict and you go into your code editor and fix it, right? This is all stuff that everyone knows. But you could imagine like an autonomous, like a rule-based system. So for example, for the example that I gave, you could say, well, if there's a conflict and one person deleted a line and the other person modified it,
也就是Docs、Sheets、演示文稿等等，用的都是同样的技术。那位先生后来离开了Google，构建了一个开源版本的同样技术。那是很久以前的事了，大概八年前。他会继续维护它，让它变得越来越好。ShareDB就是它的最新版本。我在几个不同的项目里用过它，它现在甚至可以处理JSON。想象一下，你有一个代表应用状态的JSON对象，你想让多个人同时修改这个状态，你可以使用ShareDB库，它会帮你处理WebSockets等等。
then just delete the line. So you could end up like defining rules um for how to govern these conflicts without any human intervention now it might not do what you want but it will not require any uh human in the loop right and so this is the premise for something called operational transform which is effectively just a set of rules such that you never end up in a state where you don't know what to do. And so Google Docs, any of these collaborative things, if you've ever used Notion or any of these tools, they all work under this premise like if if if patrick and i are editing a google doc together as we literally are right now and uh and patrick deletes a line right as i'm modifying it google doc doesn't pop up and say oh i have a merge conflict it has some logic to handle it and i don't know off top
所以我很喜欢这个库，我在几个项目里用过，我觉得它很有趣，上手相对容易。如果你有类似的项目，我推荐它。这真的很有趣。我刚才简单搜了一下，但因为数据库的名字和作者名字有冲突，没搜到。但很棒的是，正如你提到的，可能有很多应用最终都需要解决同样的问题。所以有一个能帮你处理这些的后端确实很酷。是的，完全同意。好了，我的下一个新闻话题是关于增强现实（AR）和虚拟现实（VR）的，这是我们讨论过的话题。
of my head what it does probably just deletes the line but but it will handle it right and so as you can imagine that handling it is not trivial um there's all sorts of weird edge cases that could happen and that you have to think about and so this library share db is actually made by the guy who made the sharing featuring Google Talks. So a bit of background, this guy built this way for people to collaborate, you know, using the browser and operational transforms, all of that. Google bought his company. That turned into a product called Google Wave that was managed, in my opinion, poorly as a product and subsequently failed. But then Google Wave was absorbed by Google Docs to make what I think is an amazing product,
这个话题让我很兴奋。每隔几年就会有进展，然后又没动静了，接着又发生点什么，我又兴奋起来。我只是希望它能成为现实，不知道什么时候会实现。Meta谈到了他们的Orion增强现实眼镜。我想他们说这太贵了，目前没有计划将其转化为产品，但他们想展示一下它是什么，大概是为了获得一些媒体关注，展示他们仍在致力于元宇宙的想法。但如果你还没看过相关报道，一定要去看看。从工程和技术的角度来看，他们正在尝试做的事情非常非常酷。
which is Docs and Sheets and presentations and all that, using that same technology. So that gentleman has since left google and built an open source version of the same technology and this was a long time ago like i think eight years ago he left google and i'll have to look up his name but um and so he's going to continue to work on it and make it better and better and better um and so share db is the latest version of it i've used this in a few different projects you know if you have something and it can actually work on json now too so imagine like you have a json object that represents the state of your app and you want multiple people to mutate this state um you can use the share db library and it will handle like the web sockets and all that stuff
再说一次，就像我说的，之前有Google Glass，各种初创公司都试图进入这个领域。感觉现在这个是领跑者，最接近那种“走在街上，眼镜上有叠加信息”的愿景。作为一个从小戴眼镜的人，我一直觉得这个领域可以放点东西。我希望我能看到一些东西，同时……希望在我们有生之年能看到这项技术实现。我觉得这会很酷。在我看来，虽然别人可能不同意，但我认为这比智能手表或手机合理得多。
for you um so i'm a big fan of library i've used it in a few projects i said i think it's really fun uh definitely it's easy relatively easy to to get started with and uh yeah if you ever have a project like this i would uh recommend it. That's really interesting. I tried briefly to search, but I was having name collision with the name of the database who wrote it. But that's awesome that, like you mentioned, it feels there's probably a bunch of apps that end up needing to solve the same issue. And so having a sort of like backend that just kind of helps you do it is actually really cool. Yeah, totally. All right. My next news topic is something that's been off and on in the news, something the topic we've covered, which is augmented reality and virtual
你现在看到很多人走在路上都在低头看手机。从情境感知（situational awareness）的角度来看，这是一个让我很烦恼的问题。前几天我跑步时，跑过了很多在外面走路的人，大概是为了锻炼，但他们真的在盯着手机看视频。我不想批评TikTok，但总之，这让我有一种“老头子别在我的草坪上”的感觉。你在外面走路，戴着耳机什么的，但你完全没在注意周围，这有点危险。而且，如果是在眼镜上显示，两件事：第一，也许他们会保持更多感知；第二，我不会知道他们在看什么，世界会变得更美好。
reality. And this one just got me really excited uh some advance happens every few years and then nothing happens uh and something happens again and i get excited again and i just i just want it to be a thing and i don't know when it was will be which is that uh meta talked about their orion augmented reality glasses i think they kind of said that it's too expensive they have no plans to make it into a product at this time but they wanted to kind of show off uh what it was presumably you know get some press around it uh show that they're still working on their kind of metaverse ideas but um you know if you haven't seen any of the coverage about it definitely check it out from an engineering and technology standpoint it's's very, very cool what they are attempting to do.
总之，向Meta致敬，Orion增强现实眼镜真的很酷。显然还有些问题需要解决，比如你不能在物体上投影黑色，所以遮蔽某些东西仍然是个挑战。但我很兴奋，哪怕只是一个非常基础、易用、不贵的小显示屏，哪怕只是眼镜上的一个闪烁灯光。让我们降低一点期望，我不在乎，只要能……也许我可以在智能家居里用它，比如有人在门口时闪烁一下。我的意思是，如果能在眼镜上收到通知，我绝对会扔掉智能手表，这样我就能少戴一个设备了。是的，这对我来说很有意义，但这确实是个难题，我知道聪明的人正在努力解决它，祝他们好运。是的，完全同意。好了，我的第二个新闻是《刀剑与魔法》（Blade and Sorcery）1.0版本发布了。我非常喜欢这个游戏。很多游戏在达到1.0版本时，其实和0.99没太大区别，你会说“好吧，恭喜你们”，但作为消费者，这其实没关系。
And again, like I said, I think there's been Google Glass, you know, these, there was, you know, various startups have attempted to get into this space. Feels like this one is now the front runner of like people who got closest to the vision of, you know, you walk down the street and you just have overlays uh on your glasses and as someone who's worn glasses since i was uh pretty young i have always been like there's this space where you could just put stuff like yeah i wish i could could see things and and you know still still not so hopefully in our lifetime uh we'll sort of get this uh you know a technology to come through i just think it would be be pretty cool. In my opinion, other people disagree, but I think it makes so much more sense than smartwatches or your phone,
但这个游戏在1.0版本进行了重大重构，变得更有趣了。天哪，我在这个游戏里投入了无数个小时。我快速说一下我的日常。我可能在节目里说过，我有种东西叫“重力手”（heavy hands），每个大约三磅，基本上是金属手套。我差点说成护手，但它们其实不保护你，只是戴在手上增加重量。我戴上这些很重的手套，依然可以握住Quest控制器，然后在游戏里挥剑和坏人战斗。这是一种惊人的锻炼，如果你戴着这些重手套挥剑一小时，你会汗流浃背。在1.0版本之前，我甚至不认为它是一个
you see so many people now just walk around like looking down at their phone. And just from a situational awareness thing as a pet peeve, I was like, out the other day, you know, doing a run, and I ran past so many people that were outside walking, presumably to get exercise and just literally staring at videos on their phone. I don't want to throw stones at tiktok but uh anyways it's just like it got to me in some like old man get off my lawn kind of way like you're outside walking around like have headphones in have like whatever but like you totally aren't paying attention it's it's a little dangerous and you know also like if it was under glasses two things one maybe they would keep more awareness and second i wouldn't know and so the world would be a better
游戏，因为它没有进度，没有钩子。基本上就是你进入竞技场，敌人出现，你和他们剑斗。它更像是一个技术演示，而不是游戏。1.0版本让它真正成为了一个游戏。有很多有趣的事情可以做，比如……我不剧透结局，但
place uh anyways so shout out for uh meta those orion you know augmented reality glasses i think are really cool uh you know there's obviously ways we still have to figure out like you can't actually like project black over something right so i actually mask something out um is is still a challenge but uh i'm excited for having just you know even a very basic just very easy to use not super expensive little bit of display you know in my glasses even just like a blinking light or something like let's just let's just get like lower our expectations a little i don't really care just something that'll uh maybe i can put one up in my smart home you know a little light that flashes when someone's at my
有一个小BOSS，如果你玩过《星际火狐》（Star Fox）或其他游戏，敌人有弱点，BOSS也有弱点。但弱点可能在很高的地方，而这个小BOSS非常高，大概20英尺。弱点可能在他的头顶。所以你必须在他乱晃试图把你甩下来的时候，爬到他的背上，爬到他的头顶，开始用剑砍他。非常令人振奋。我玩的时候从来不会晕船，可能是我玩了太多90年代的《毁灭战士》（Doom）之类的游戏，我对它免疫。但我能想象其他人玩这个会晕，因为这个家伙会把你甩来甩去，你得努力抓住他，还要攀爬这个巨大的东西。所以，非常非常有趣。他们增加了技能树，
front door or something i mean i would definitely get rid of my smart watch if i could just get notifications on my glasses so it's like one less device i'd have to wear yeah i it makes sense to me but it's just a it's a hard problem and i think smart people are working on it i i wish them luck yeah totally um all right my second news blade and sorcery 1.0 is out um i totally love this game um you know a lot of games when they get to 1.0 it's not really that different than 0.99 you're like okay well you know, a lot of games when they get to 1.0, it's not really that different than 0.99. You're like, okay, well, you know, congratulations to you. But for me as a consumer, it really doesn't matter.
我把所有技能都点在了运动能力上，所以我根本不玩《刀剑与魔法》里的魔法部分，我只是把技能点在能更用力地挥剑上，这和锻炼部分很契合。我觉得非常有趣，而且绝对物有所值，价格很合理，我觉得它不是那种60美元的游戏。我还没试过这个，好奇我是否应该试试。我试过《Gorn》，人们很喜欢《Gorn》，《Gorn》也不错。好吧，我不喜欢那个，所以也许我不会喜欢这个。从相关性来说，这个比《Gorn》好上一百万倍。方向上和《Gorn》一样，如果你不喜欢《Gorn》的整个前提，你可能不会喜欢这个，但这把体验提升到了一个新的高度。
But this game had a major, major overhaul in 1.0 that made it even more fun. Oh man, I mean, I've put just countless hours into this game. So I'll tell you my routine really quick. I might've already said this on show, but I have these things called heavy hands. They're about like three pounds each and they're basically metal gloves. I almost said gauntlets, but they're not really, they don't protect you at all. gloves that you wear on top of your hands that just add a lot of weight and uh i'll put on these like really heavy gloves uh you can still hold the the uh quest controllers with them and i'll basically swing swords and and you know fight bad guys and stuff in this game and that's like an amazing workout you will sweat bullets uh if you wear these heavy gloves and try and swing a sword around for an hour. Up until 1.0 it wasn't really even I would consider
但这款游戏在1.0版本中进行了重大改进，变得更加有趣了。天哪，我的意思是，我在这个游戏上投入了无数的时间。所以我很快告诉你我的日常安排。我可能已经在节目中说过了，但我有种东西叫重力手套。它们大约每只三磅重，基本上就是金属手套。我差点说成护手，但它们并不是，它们根本无法保护你。这些手套戴在手上，只是增加了很大的重量。呃，我会戴上这些非常重的手套，呃，你仍然可以用它们握住Quest控制器，我基本上会在这个游戏里挥舞剑，和坏人战斗之类的，这是一种很棒的锻炼。如果你戴着这些重手套并试图挥舞剑一个小时，你会汗流浃背的。在1.0版本之前，我甚至不认为它算是一个
a game in the sense that there's no progression, there's no hook. It's basically like you go in an arena and enemies show up and you sword fight them. But it wasn't really, it was more of a tech demo uh than a game um 1.0 makes it truly a game um there is so many fun things you do just for example uh not to i won't spoil the ending or anything like that but but
游戏，因为没有进度，没有吸引人的地方。基本上就像你进入一个竞技场，敌人出现，你和他们进行剑斗。但这并不算真正的游戏，它更像是一个技术演示，而不是一个游戏。1.0版本让它真正成为了一款游戏。有很多有趣的事情可以做，举个例子，呃，我不会剧透结局之类的，但是
there's a mini boss that you fight and he's got like a kind of like if you ever played the game star fox or any of these games where the enemy has like a weakness like a certain point that's a weakness so the boss has a weakness point but it could be like way up high and and the mini boss is uh extremely tall so like 20 feet tall. And the weakness might be like on the top of his head. And so you literally have to climb on this boss's back while he's like thrashing around and trying to get you off of his back. You have to climb on his back, get to the top of his head and start whacking him with a sword. exhilarating um i actually never get seasick or anything like that playing i'm unfortunate maybe it's just too many years of playing uh pixelated doom and these other games in the 90s but uh i'm somehow immune to it um but i i could imagine like pretty much anybody else getting sick on this because this guy's like throwing you around and you're trying to hold on and you're trying to like wall climb uh rock climb this this giant thing so um extremely extremely fun uh they added like skills so you can like there's a skill
有一个小头目，你和他战斗，他有一种，如果你玩过《星际火狐》或者任何这类游戏，敌人有一个弱点，比如某个特定的点是弱点，所以这个头目有一个弱点，但它可能在很高的地方，而且这个小头目非常高，大约20英尺高。弱点可能在他的头顶上。所以你必须在他挣扎着想把你甩掉的时候，爬到他的背上。你必须爬上他的背，到达他的头顶，开始用剑猛击他。令人振奋。我玩的时候从来不会晕船之类的，我很幸运，也许是因为我在90年代玩了太多年的像素化《毁灭战士》和其他游戏，但我不知何故对它免疫。但我可以想象，几乎任何其他人玩这个都会感到恶心，因为这家伙会把你甩来甩去，你试图抓住他，试图攀爬这个巨大的东西。所以，非常非常有趣。他们增加了技能，所以你可以，有一个技能
tree um i put all the skills into the athletic stuff so i actually don't do any of the sorcery part in blade and sorcery i just put all the skills into being able to like hit people harder with the swords um which goes along with the exercise part of it um i found it extremely fun and it is totally worth uh whatever they're charging which is pretty reasonable i don't think it's like a 60 game or anything i've so i haven't tried this one i'm curious if i should i tried the gorn people were like really into gorn and gorn is good too okay i don't like that so then maybe i won't like this one by a correlation this is a million times better so it's it's directionally the same as gorn so like if you didn't like the whole premise of gorn you might not like this one but this takes it to the next level for
树。我把所有的技能都点在了运动能力上，所以我根本不做《刀剑与魔法》里的巫术部分，我只是把所有的技能都点在了能用剑更用力地打击敌人上，这与锻炼部分相辅相成。我觉得它非常有趣，而且绝对值得他们收取的费用，这相当合理。我不认为它是一款60美元的游戏之类的。我还没试过这个，我在想我是否应该试试。我试过《Gorn》，人们非常喜欢《Gorn》，《Gorn》也不错。好吧，我不喜欢那个，所以也许我不会喜欢这个。从相关性来看，这个比那个好一百万倍。所以它在方向上和《Gorn》是一样的，所以如果你不喜欢《Gorn》的整个前提，你可能不会喜欢这个，但这让它提升到了一个新的水平
sure maybe i just i you seem to be into very skill skillful uh vr stuff i've never i was more do like the puzzle puzzle games like uh escape room i expect you to die that kind of stuff has been been my go to oh yeah the like let me get better at the game itself. I just, yeah, I haven't, I guess I should keep, keep trying. I think partly I don't get super, super motion sick, but I do a little bit.
当然，也许我只是……你似乎对非常高超的VR技术很感兴趣。我从来没有……我更喜欢解谜游戏，比如密室逃脱，《我期待你死》（I Expect You to Die）这类游戏一直是我的首选。哦，是的，就像“让我在这款游戏本身上变得更强”。我只是，是的，我还没……我想我应该继续尝试。我觉得部分原因是我不会感到特别严重的晕动症，但确实有一点。
And so the ones that are more aggressively like move around and, uh, you know, be fast and quick. I feel like you see the limitations of your VR system quicker, um, because of update rates and stuff versus, you know,
所以那些动作更剧烈、需要快速移动的游戏，我觉得你会更快地看到VR系统的局限性，因为刷新率之类的原因，相比之下，你知道……
slow and I can move move but it's a more applauding pace isn't isn't as a problematic yeah i mean so i just checked it's 30 dollars uh i think you can refund it within 48 hours so you could always grab it and then say like oh i'm vomiting my brain's not um uh yeah so so do you use a broomstick handle as your sword like is there a danger of whacking your tv or any other people in the room that's an interesting idea i never thought about that that would be pretty cool someone should make basically what i've what i've done but with a broomstick handle so like you know a really heavy glove that goes on the outside that doesn't interfere with your thumb so you can still play right and then a broomstick handle for the sword so you can whack yourself in the head I know
节奏缓慢，我可以移动，但节奏更从容，就不会那么成问题。是的，我的意思是，我刚查了一下，是30美元。我想你可以在48小时内退款，所以你随时可以买下来，然后说：“哦，我在呕吐，我的大脑不行了。”嗯……是的，那么你用扫帚柄当剑吗？有没有打到电视或房间里其他人的危险？这是一个有趣的想法，我从来没想过。那会很酷，有人应该制造出我所做的东西，但用扫帚柄。比如，你知道，外面戴一副很重的手套，不会干扰你的拇指，这样你仍然可以玩，对吧？然后用扫帚柄做剑，这样你就可以打到自己的头了。我知道。
that I know they have them like 3d printed like gun rifle like attachments for some of the shooting games and stuff there they don't look like guns they're just degenerate but you know hold the hold the handles a proper spacing apart or feel a little bit like a pistol grip or whatever for for some of the oh cool i've seen online i i as a 3d printing person you kind of bump across those things sometimes so i wouldn't be surprised if someone has you know iron pipe but no i'd probably break a snap but like uh yeah anyway something heavy to attach and really get a workout yeah it's super fun actually if you if you had something really long you'd get that cantilever force right so i was gonna say that heavy you just need something with those olympic weight lifting weight attachments to the end and you could put like a 10 pound plate you know a foot out from you oh that was so hard you couldn't like the torque would be
我知道他们有那种3D打印的枪支步枪附件，用于一些射击游戏之类的。它们看起来不像枪，只是退化的，但你知道，保持手柄适当的间距，或者感觉有点像手枪握把之类的，对于一些……哦，很酷。我在网上见过，作为一个玩3D打印的人，你有时会偶然发现这些东西，所以如果有人有，你知道，铁管，我也不惊讶。但不行，我可能会弄断它。但就像……是的，总之，用一些重的东西来连接，真的能锻炼身体。是的，实际上超级有趣。如果你有一些非常长的东西，你就会得到那种悬臂力，对吧？所以我正要说，那个重物，你只需要在末端加上那些奥林匹克举重配重附件，你就可以在离你一英尺远的地方放一个10磅的杠铃片。哦，那太难了，你不能……扭矩会……
you know or go a meter out and then you do like a pound at end of a meter and you'd just be like oh and then it's like i have to explain to my family why there's like a olympic weight-sized hole in the wall i guess i mixed my i'm gonna make people. I said a pound a meter away. You'd have to 500 grams a meter away. There we go. Yeah. We're in America. You have to do it in like dove farlings. It's a half stone at a furlong distance. All right. Book of the show. Mine's an actual legit book this time. That is The Book That Wouldn't Burn by Mark Lawrence. I've recommended a series from Mark Lawrence before, and this is the first book in a series. I'm not actually done with it yet,
你知道，或者在一米外，然后在末端放一磅重物，你就会觉得“哦”。然后就像我得向家人解释为什么墙上有一个奥林匹克举重大小的洞。我想我搞混了，我要让人……我说在一米外放一磅。你得在离你一米远的地方放500克。这就对了。是的，我们在美国。你得用“多夫法隆”（dove farlings）来衡量。这是一英里距离的一半。好了，节目推荐书。这次我的是一本真正的书，是马克·劳伦斯的《不会燃烧的书》（The Book That Wouldn't Burn）。我之前推荐过马克·劳伦斯的一个系列，这是该系列的第一本书。我其实还没读完，
but I am enjoying it so far. I will say for me personally, it was a bit of a slow start. I kind of just went off of, you know, recommendation that it was an author and it was getting good reviews. And I didn't even read the description. I kind of just went off of, you know, recommendation that it was an author and it was getting good reviews.
但我目前很喜欢它。我得说，对我个人而言，开头有点慢。我只是根据推荐，因为它是这位作者写的，而且评价很好。我甚至没读简介。我只是根据推荐，因为它是这位作者写的，而且评价很好。
And I didn't even read the description. So it was a bit like trying to figure out what it was going. And then I kind of got excited. And then I was like, when to prepare for this and read the summary. And I was like, oh, this was just like literally the back of the book. Okay. Anyways, but definitely been an interesting parallel storylines that intertwine telling of a kind of interesting world. I don't know the full details yet, but one of those things where rather than tell you all of the stuff up front, you're just kind of learning as the characters sort of go through their story. And there's some interesting ideas uh and sort of a
我甚至没读简介。所以有点像是在试图弄清楚它要讲什么。然后我有点兴奋了。然后我就想，什么时候准备读这个，读了摘要。然后我就想，哦，这简直就是书的封底内容。好吧。总之，绝对是引人入胜的平行故事线，交织在一起讲述了一个相当有趣的世界。我还不知道全部细节，但这是那种与其一开始就告诉你所有事情，不如随着角色经历他们的故事而逐渐了解的情况。而且有一些有趣的想法，嗯，还有一种
mysterious world that's being inhabited and you're trying to figure out you know how similar or dissimilar uh is this and so i definitely check it out book that wouldn't burn by mark lawrence if you're into that kind of like science fiction fantasy if you've read something from uh from mark lawrence before uh very cool so it's the first book of the trilogy? It is the first book in a new series. Okay. So yeah, you have to be prepared to wait for the second. Oh, okay.
神秘的世界，你正居住在其中，你试图弄清楚，你知道，这与现实有多相似或不相似。所以我绝对会去看看马克·劳伦斯的《不会燃烧的书》，如果你喜欢那种科幻奇幻作品的话。如果你之前读过马克·劳伦斯的作品，非常酷。所以这是三部曲的第一本？这是新系列的第一本书。好的。所以是的，你得做好等待第二本的准备。哦，好的。
Yeah, fair point. I guess I should have told people that the library trilogy, I think the first and second book are already out. And the author, yeah, the third one isn't yet, but this author mark lawrence has been able to finish multiple series before so it's not their first rodeo yeah right that's not not name calling any specific patrick rothfuss anyways that they can't finish their series um if you're listening patrick if you're here for you,
是的，有道理。我想我应该告诉人们，关于图书馆三部曲，我想第一本和第二本已经出版了。作者，是的，第三本还没有，但这位作者马克·劳伦斯之前已经完成了多个系列，所以这不是他第一次干这行了。是的，没错，这不是在点名批评帕特里克·罗斯福斯，总之，他们无法完成他们的系列。嗯，如果你在听，帕特里克，如果你在这里，为了你，
man. Yeah. We get back to work. I've heard much worse things said to him. So I feel, I do feel bad. I do feel bad for them. Yeah,
伙计。是的。我们回去工作吧。我听过比这难听得多的话对他说了。所以我确实感到难过。我确实为他们感到难过。是的，
totally. No one likes to be stressed to be, to do something creative. I mean, that's like, people probably have no, no idea what we're talking about. My book of the show is also a book. It's called Masters of Doom.
完全同意。没人喜欢在做创造性工作时感到压力。我的意思是，人们可能根本不知道我们在说什么。我的节目推荐书也是一本书。它叫《毁灭战士大师》（Masters of Doom）。
And it is a biography of John Carmack and John Romero, two of the founders of its software that created Doom. It's awesome. I mean, I'm a huge fan. I put countless hours as a kid into doom into commander keen uh into uh so many of these shareware games uh kingdom of craws is actually mentioned uh they work closely with scott miller who made kingdom of craws um so it was just like a total nostalgia trip uh if you're not you know a millennial uh maybe this
它是约翰·卡马克和约翰·罗梅罗的传记，他们是创造《毁灭战士》的id Software公司的两位创始人。太棒了。我的意思是，我是个超级粉丝。我小时候在《毁灭战士》、《指挥官基恩》、《王国之战》上投入了无数时间，嗯，还有很多共享软件游戏。实际上提到了《王国之战》，他们与制作《王国之战》的斯科特·米勒密切合作。所以这简直是一次彻底的怀旧之旅。如果你不是，你知道，千禧一代，也许这
won't relate like it uh but uh man it just really threw me down memory lane um so fun i am about two-thirds of the way through it um and i'm just having absolute blast listening to this book. One of the interesting things is they really talk about, some of the people wanted to make a really gory demon-like game since the beginning, but they started off making Commander Keen and making kind of some of these silly games but you know they always had this big vision at least on the artistic side
不会引起共鸣，但……伙计，它真的让我陷入了回忆。太有趣了。我读了大约三分之二了，我听这本书听得非常开心。有趣的事情之一是，他们真的谈到了，有些人从一开始就想制作一款非常血腥的恶魔类游戏，但他们最初制作的是《指挥官基恩》，制作了一些愚蠢的游戏，但你知道，他们至少在艺术方面一直有这个宏大的愿景。
you know on the technical side John Carmack's always been kind of like head and shoulders above all his contemporaries which is I think pretty admirable and they talk a lot about that overall I thought it was uh i think it's a fantastic read i'd recommend folks to check it out i have read that book i was actually looking
你知道，在技术方面，约翰·卡马克一直比他所有的同代人都高出一筹，我认为这非常令人钦佩。他们谈了很多关于这一点。总的来说，我认为这是一本非常棒的书，我建议大家去看看。我读过那本书，我其实在
quickly i was for sure i probably recommended this but i have not so uh yeah good good recommendation um on uh masters of doom like you said i actually didn't play a lot of the games that were talked about there, but I kind of knew about them. But reading about, I don't call it like the dichotomy between folks
快速查看，我确定我可能推荐过这个，但我没有。所以，是的，很好的推荐。关于《毁灭战士大师》，正如你所说，我其实并没有玩过里面提到的很多游戏，但我对它们有所了解。但是阅读关于……我不称之为艺术与技术之间的二分法，而约翰·卡马克，你知道，直到今天，我觉得他依然活跃，而且，你知道，
just trying to push for artistic versus like technical and John Carmack, you know, still today, I feel like is around and, you know,
我们之前在谈论VR，他在Meta和Oculus那边做了一些事情。但是，你知道，我们之前在谈论VR，他在Meta和Oculus那边做了一些事情。但是，你知道，我认为对于很多人来说，他绝对是编程领域一个非常有影响的人物，以及他
we were talking about VR and had some stuff going on there with Meta and Oculus and the work he was doing there. But, you know, we were talking about VR and had some stuff going on there with, with meta and Oculus and the work he was doing there. But, you know, I think definitely like for a lot of people, a very formative figure in the programming space and sort of the way he
处理事情的方式，他做事的方式，只是……只是勇往直前，而且，你知道，这是一种罕见的天赋。但绝对是一本有趣的读物，即使仅仅是为了看看那些回顾，
approached things and the way he did things and just, just kind of going for it and, you know, kind of a rare, a rare talent there. But, but definitely an interesting read even if for nothing else it's kind of interesting to start to see those retrospectives of things
主要是软件或编程方面的，对吧？并没有那么多关于编程真正成为主角的作品，而在这里它确实是。所以我们正处于可以进行那些历史回顾的阶段。我最近也偶然看到埃隆·马斯克推荐的一些书单，并不是说支持他，但这本书在他的名单上。所以我认为你……我想，也许你可以，那是相关性，对吧？如果你们读并推荐相同的书，那么你们就会有相同的结果和财富。所以，是的，我最终将能够用筷子夹住东西。我的意思是，我几乎一生都在尝试夹点心，但我做不到。
that are largely software or programming right there's not that that many of them where programming is really the i don't know star of the show and and here here it kind of was and so uh we're kind of getting to the point where you can have those historic lookbacks. I also did happen to see recently randomly some recommended book lists from Elon Musk, not that endorsement of him, but this book was on his list. So I think you're in, I guess, maybe you can, that's correlation, right? If you guys read and recommend the same books, then you're going to have the same outcome and wealth wealth so yeah i will eventually be able to catch something with chopsticks i mean i've been trying basically my whole life to pick up a dim sum i can't do it
那是真的，我真的不擅长用真正的筷子，所以也许我应该设计机器人筷子，也许我会做得更好。没错。好了，节目工具时间到了。好吧，我为节目推荐了一本书，我没有为节目推荐工具。没关系。嗯，我推荐《Balatro》，这是一个非常奇怪的东西，我从来不说它。它只是我总是看到的那些词之一，但B-A-L-A-T-R-O，我猜你称它为Roguelike游戏。是的，没错，Roguelike。它在PC上已经存在一段时间了，但最近在Android和iOS上发布了移动版。所以你现在可以在手机上玩它了，这在一段时间内对我的空闲时间非常不利。
that's true i ain't really bad at actual chopsticks so maybe i should engineer robotic chopsticks maybe i would do better that's right all right times for tool of the show well i did a book for book of the show i'm not doing a tool for tool of the show that's okay uh i'm doing belatro which is a very weird thing i don't ever say it it's just one of those words i always see but b-a-l-a-t-r-o which is a i guess you call it a roguelike uh yeah that's right roguelike. It's been around for a while on PC, but it recently had mobile releases on Android and iOS. And so you can now play it mobily, which is very bad for my free time for a while.
我其实一直在我的Steam Deck上玩它，这对……你知道。总之，他有他那花哨的Steam Deck，而我所做的只是玩这个纸牌游戏。总之，在我的iPhone上玩要好得多。但我一直在玩，它是那种完美平衡了随机性，你可以尽力而为，但仍然会输的游戏。我有时和我的孩子们一起玩游戏，他们认为自己太棒了，我试图向他们表达：你意识到你采取了一个非常糟糕的策略，
I'd been playing it on my Steam Deck actually, and it was bad for, you know. Anyways, get his fancy Steam Deck and all I did was play this card game. Anyways, it was much better on my my iphone uh but i've been playing it it's one of those like perfectly finds the bounce of like it's random and you can do as good as you can and you still just lose and i play kids with play games with my kids sometimes and they think they're just amazing and i try to like express to them you realize you you took a very bad strategy you
你需要一个特定的、极不可能的结果连续出现四次才能获胜，而你做到了。是的，你赢了，但我不确定你应该为此感到特别自豪。总之，这就是那个游戏。有时你只是抽到了非常非常糟糕的牌，或者其他什么，你可能会输，但你总是可以尝试提高你的概率。我觉得玩这些游戏，你不能想太多。你只需要快速行动。没有……不要陷入分析瘫痪。你只需要快速通过，尽力而为。但绝对玩得很开心。
needed a specific very unlikely outcome four times in a row to win and you got it like yes you won but like i don't know that you should be super proud anyways this is that game sometimes you're just really really bad draws or whatever and you can lose but you can always just be trying to improve your probabilities and i feel like with these games, you can't overthink it. You just got to kind of go fast. There's no don't get analysis paralysis. You just kind of zip through it and try to do your best. But definitely been having a good time.
我想它是在……我是从Apple Arcade还是什么地方得到的。所以我没付钱。但我相信它在各个平台上都不算太贵。所以如果你以前从未听说过它或从未尝试过，我绝对会为它点赞，适合坐飞机、坐公交、坐火车、坐在车里有几分钟空闲的时候。绝对不要在你上厕所的时候玩。
I think it comes in. I got it off of Apple Arcade or whatever. So I didn't pay for it. But I believe it's not super expensive on the various platforms. So if you've never heard of it before or never tried it, I would definitely give it a shout out for that plane ride, bus ride, train ride, sitting in the car, having a few minutes. Definitely not while you're using the restroom.
绝对不要在你上厕所的时候用手机。但那是玩几把《Balatro》的绝佳机会。好的，这里有个小题外话，好的，但抱歉，你完全可以在厕所里用手机，没问题。不，真的，你在开玩笑吗？还是你……不，不，抱歉，我只是……好吧，继续。好的，但你知道你不能做什么吗？你不能在厕所隔间里用笔记本电脑，而且你绝对不能把笔记本电脑放在厕所隔间的地上。我曾经在工作中看到过一次，我就想：这简直是恶心到了新高度。这就像……嗯……那些不知为何在小便池里吐痰的人，我也不理解，但这甚至比那更糟。
Definitely don't use your phone when you do. But those are the perfect opportunities for getting in a few hands for Metro. Okay, small digression here okay but sorry you can use your phone in the restroom totally fine no really are you joking or are you no no i'm sorry i i was just like go ahead okay but you know what you cannot do you cannot use your laptop in a toilet stall and then you definitely cannot put the laptop on the ground on the toilet stall like i saw this one time at work and i was like this is like a whole new level of disgusting like this is like uh um like those people who for some reason like spit in the urinal i don't understand that either but like this is like even worse than
这就像：哦，我需要把我的笔记本电脑放在厕所隔间的地板上。你在想什么？我……让我们……我不能，我必须继续。让我们继续。我不想知道你在哪里玩游戏。我不想知道你在哪里玩游戏。我不想知道你在哪里用Slack给我发消息。只是……让我们保持这样。没关系。是的，我们不需要在这个节目里谈论排泄物。哦，不。是的，别把你的厕所……别把你的笔记本电脑带进厕所隔间。
that this is like oh i need to put my laptop on the floor of the toilet stall like what are you thinking i i let's just i can't i just gotta keep going let's keep going i don't want to know where you're playing your games from i don't know where you're playing your games from. I don't want to know where you're slacking me from. Just like, let's just keep it. It's fine. Yeah, we don't need to go scatological on this show. Oh, no. Yeah, don't bring your toilet. Don't bring your laptop into the toilet stall.
别那样做。没那么重要。代码可以等，你知道。好了，我的节目工具是，而且我其实认为这是一个令人难以置信的惊人工具，它叫Cursor。它是一个IDE。嗯，我猜因为某种限制，他们不能仅仅把它做成Visual Studio Code的一个扩展，所以他们不得不实际进行分叉。疯狂的事情，例如，我重命名了一个函数，它就像：“嘿，你知道你调用了这个函数，在你的代码库的其他所有地方，你想让我为你修复它吗？”我就说：“当然。”嗯，我认为这在不同的东西中已经存在了，你知道，我们在很久以前的NetBeans中就有那个重构选项。但后来它变得越来越复杂，以至于你在改变东西，它会跳到文件的不同位置和其他文件，就像：“嘿，你应该这样做，你应该那样做。”我为一个函数写了一个文档字符串。当我完成后，它跳到了下一个函数，
Just don't do it. It's not that important. That code can wait, you know. All right, my tool of the show is, and actually I thought an unbelievably amazing tool it's called cursor it's a ide um i i guess because of whatever limitations they couldn't just make this an extension on visual studio code so they had to actually fork wild things like for example i renamed a function and it was like hey you know you called this function and like all these other places all
并开始为我写文档字符串。它就像：“嘿，看起来你处于文档字符串编写模式。让我们继续写文档字符串。”我觉得这太棒了。我认为它对Copilot和其他这些工具构成了真正的威胁，所以我认为微软可能正在努力让真正的Visual Studio Code做一些这些事情。但是的，我以前真的没有体验过那样的IDE。
over your code base you want me to fix it for you i was like sure um that i think already exists you know in different different things like we've had that refactor option in NetBeans a long time ago. But then it just kind of got more and more sophisticated to where you're changing things and it's hopping to different points of the file and other files and like, hey, you should do this, you should do that. And I wrote a doc string for a function. And when I was done, it jumped to the next function
所以它是完全免费的。我认为它是一个基于使用量的模型。所以如果你写代码足够多，你最终会达到某种限制。我还没用它用到达到任何限制。但到那时，或者也许是一个时间限制。我不太确定。但到某个时候，你将不得不开始为它付费。但他们有一个相当慷慨的免费层级。所以我完全推荐大家去尝试一下。这太疯狂了。我没用过，但我得说你谈论的一些东西已经被讨论过了。我当时在听Lex Friedman的播客，他采访了Cursor团队，那些在那里的人。他们谈论了一点为什么分叉Visual Studio Code，为什么不是插件？插件。我还谈论了一些在人机交互方面的一些困难。然后还有如何在彼此之间权衡各种模型选择，以用于潜在的不同任务，甚至只是建议差异流以及它将如何工作。所以如果这
and started a docstring for me. It's like, hey, it looks like you're in docstring writing mode. Let's keep writing docstring. I thought it was awesome. I think it's a real threat to Copilot and to these other tools, and so I would imagine Microsoft's probably hard at work to make the actual Visual Studio Code do some of these things. But yeah, I hadn't really experienced IDE like that before.
是一个你感兴趣的话题，我会为那个播客点赞。它绝对不是一个短播客。我猜我们的也不短。嗯，但如果你感兴趣，他们……这是一个有趣的讨论。他们还谈论了一点关于如何判断LLM是否有点像智能，你认为它们能或不能解决什么问题，比如程度是多少。所以我认为那是一个有趣的收听。所以是的，完全同意。我……我绝对属于这一阵营，因为无论什么原因，我……嗯……我没有那么多……哦，你知道，这是因为我一直在车里读这些书，而不是做播客。所以我一直在读《毁灭战士大师》和其他一些
So it's totally free. I think it's a usage-based model. So if you code enough, you'll eventually hit some kind of a limit. I haven't used it enough to hit any limit. But at that point, or maybe it's a time limit. I'm not totally sure. But at some point, you'll have to start paying for it. But they have a pretty generous free tier. So I totally recommend folks trying it out. It's pretty wild. I haven't used it, but I will say some of the stuff you're talking about was discussed. I was listening to the Lex Friedman podcast and he interviewed the team at Cursor, the folks that are there. And they talked a bit about why fork Visual Studio Code, why not a plugin? plugin. I also talked about some of the difficulties in sort of the human machine interaction. And then also like how to trade off various models selection between each other for potentially different tasks and just even the suggestion diff flow and how that would work. So if this
书。但因为那个，我一直在积累我想看的东西的通知。所以我手机上有所有这些Lex Friedman剧集的通知。我不想清除它们，但我似乎也没有足够的时间去处理它们。是的，我有。当我锻炼时，我倾向于听书。我还没听完书。我开车时听书，锻炼时听播客，这是我的平衡。是的，我想你一针见血。我确实需要锻炼。
is a topic that's interesting to you, I'll give a shout out to that podcast. It's definitely not a short podcast. i guess ours isn't very short either um but if you're interested they it is an interesting discussion they also talk a little bit about you know how to tell if lms are are kind of like intelligent what problems do you think they could or couldn't solve like what's the extent um so i thought that that it was an interesting listen so yeah totally i've i've uh i'm definitely in this camp where for whatever reason i um uh i haven't had as much oh you know it's because i've been reading books in the car instead of doing podcasts so i've been doing masters of doom and some of these other
我不会去做的。我会把那段长篇大论留到下次再说。好了。那么让我们进入话题：在家工作。所以让我在这里设定一下背景。嗯，我最初对在家工作感兴趣是在2018年、2019年左右，当时我们决定搬到德克萨斯州。所以基本上……你知道，这是在新冠疫情之前，在所有这些之前。而且……你知道，湾区的科技工作无疑比德克萨斯州的任何城市都要多。所以在家工作似乎是一个不错的方式，我们可以
books but uh because of that i've been accumulating notifications of things that I want to watch. So I have on my phone all these notifications of all these episodes of Lex Friedman. And I don't want to clear them, but I also don't seem to have enough time to get to them. Yeah, I do. While I'm exercising, I tend to listen to books. I haven't done listening to books. Books when I drive, podcasts when I exercise has been my balance. Yeah, I think you hit the nail on the head. I need to actually exercise.
搬到离家人更近的地方，所有这些，但我仍然可以保留我真正喜欢的工作。当时，这不是一个选择。所以我正在德克萨斯州面试面对面的工作，因为我非常坚定地要搬家，当时疫情爆发了。我记得我当时其实生病了。我不认为我得了新冠。我想我只是得了普通的感冒，但……但我生病了，嗯，在他们说“这是你可以来办公室的最后一天”的时候。我当时……我病得很重。所以我甚至不能去拿我的东西。所以花了我大概半年时间才把我的东西从办公室拿出来，因为在某个时候他们完全关闭了它。嗯，而且……嗯……所以在那一点上我决定：“嘿，好吧，我们都在这里在家工作。”
I'm not going to. I'll save that diatribe for another time. All right. So let's jump into the topic working from home. So let me set the stage here um i uh originally got interested in working from home around 2018 2019 when we decided to move to texas and so basically uh you know this is pre-covid pre all of that and um you know there are undoubtedly a lot more tech jobs in the Bay Area than there are in any city in Texas. And so working from home seemed like a nice way where we could
我不如就做这个搬迁。所以，我们确实搬到了德克萨斯州。所以我就……工作了一段时间。嗯，所以，你知道，正如许多其他人一样……嗯……所以然后在某个时候，公司重新开放了，现在我们正在经历一场关于RTO或重返办公室的大辩论。所以值得注意的是，亚马逊表示他们的员工必须每周五天来办公室。他们甚至更进一步说，
move closer to family and all of that, but still I could keep the the jobs I really enjoyed. At the time, it wasn't an option. And so I was in the middle of interviewing for in-person jobs in Texas because I was pretty committed to move when the pandemic hit. And I remember I was actually sick. I don't think I had COVID. I think I just had a regular cold, but, but I was sick, uh, during the time when they said like, this is the last day you can come into the office. And I was, I was super sick. And so I actually couldn't even go in and get my stuff. And so it took me like probably half a year to get my stuff out of the office because at some point they just completely shut it down. Um, and, uh, um, and so at that point I decided, Hey, well, we're all working from home here.
如果你在卫星办公室，如果你像纳什维尔的那一个人，即使你在亚马逊办公室，那也不够好。你必须去你团队其他成员所在的地方。所以即使是办公室里的人也必须搬到另一个办公室。我想这可能是最极端的版本。然后还有整个梯度。我知道戴尔说如果你远程工作就不能获得晋升，
I might as well make this, make this move. So, so we did move to Texas. And so I worked, uh, worked from home for a while. Um, and so, you know, as did a lot of other people um um and so then at some point uh companies opened back up and now what we're experiencing is a big debate around uh rto or return to office so notably you, Amazon has said that their employees have to come into the office five days a week. They even went a step further and said,
我认为这其实不太明智。我觉得这会产生各种奇怪的副作用，依我之见，但他们确实那样做了。然后一直到光谱的另一端，像Figma这样的公司，讽刺的是，Twitch（归亚马逊所有），真的在另一个方向上采取了立场，说：“不，你知道，远程办公将持续存在，远程办公更好。我们永远不会放弃远程办公。”真的在那里采取了立场。这就是我们现在所处的真正的十字路口。你对此有什么看法，目前的局势？是的，我想你对它的总结很不错。我会
if you're in a satellite office, if you're like the one person in Nashville, even if you're at an Amazon office, that's not good enough. You have to go to where the rest of your team is. So even people in the office have to move to a different office. That's maybe, I think, the most extreme version. Then there's a whole gradient. I know Dell said you can't get promoted if you're working remote,
说，我们（你知道）过去做过很多面试，我认为我们交谈过的很多公司对远程工作都有强烈的看法，我想其中很多甚至是在新冠疫情之前。我会说，我认为围绕远程工作的工具、期望以及我们今天试图谈论的一些东西，嗯……在过去，你知道，自新冠疫情以来，以及每个人都不得不去尝试一段时间以来，已经进化了很多。我认为人们对它的含义有了更好的理解。而且有很多公司是建立在某种基础上，说：“无论他们在哪里，我们都想要最好的人才。我们将围绕它建立一种文化。”
which I thought was actually not very smart. I feel like that creates all sorts of weird side effects, my opinion, but they did that. And then all the way to on the other end of the spectrum, companies like Figma, actually, ironically, Twitch, which is owned by Amazon, really taking a stand in the other direction and saying, no, you know, remote is here to stay, remote is better. And we will never give up on remote, really taking a stand there. And that's kind of where we're at right now at this real crossroads. What's your take on that, the current situation? Yeah, i think you have a decent summary of it i'll
而且我确实认为这非常重要。但我还要在这里介绍中提到的另一件事是，在家工作至少有两个非常重要的部分，即公司和公司的文化以及公司的期望，但还有个人。就像有很多很多种公司一样，也有很多很多种个人情况。所以我认为对两者进行还原论，认为只能有一家公司……嗯，我的意思是，我猜在这里插入一个自由市场论点，但也认为每个人都是一样的。而且因为你有一种特定的方式，这真的是我见过的最极端的事情之一，真正花时间与他人沟通并产生共鸣，也许是他们的情况、他们的健康、身体设置、他们的家庭情况、他们的无论什么，
say we you know used to do a lot of interviews and i think a lot of the companies we talked to had strong opinions on remote work and i was i think a lot of those were even before before covid i will say i think the tooling around remote work and the expectations and some of the stuff i think we're going to try to talk about today um is is evolved a lot in the last you know since covid and and sort of everybody went and had to go do it for a while i think there's a better understanding of of what it means um and there are a lot of companies that were built sort of ground up saying we want the best people no matter where they are. We're going to build up a culture around it.
可能与你的差异如此之大，以至于很难理解他们想要在办公室工作或不必来办公室的愿望。然后，你知道，正如杰森提到的，我猜把这一切搞得混乱的是那些被迫改变或随时间改变的事情。嗯，任何时候我认为有变化，它也是……困难的，因为人们处理或应对变化的能力可能会有所不同。所以……嗯，我认为所有这些使它成为一个并非“一刀切”的话题，但我确实认为有一些事情可以谈论，你知道，如果你要全职或兼职在家工作，我认为有一些事情你可以做，
And I do actually think that that's really important. But the other thing I'll just say to bring up here in the intro is there are two, at least two very important pieces of work from home, which is company and the company's culture and the company's expectations, but then also personal. And just like there are many, many kinds of companies, there are many, many personal situations. And so I think to be reductionist about either, that there can only be one company, well, I mean, I guess insert a free market argument here, but also to have a belief that everybody is the same. And because you have a certain way that you are, it's really one of those things, almost one of the most extreme ones I've seen where really taking time to communicate with others and empathize, maybe their situation, their health, physical setup, their family situation, their whatever
去意识到，去帮助自己，去思考它。而且我确实同意，从你知道的远程工作、全远程工作、混合计划存在一个光谱。而且我认为展望未来，我有很高的信心，我可以说是他们都可能会遇到更多的多样性，比新冠疫情前有更多的公司和工作种类。新冠疫情前，几乎总是全职五天或更多天在办公室的期望。而且很少有公司是完全远程的。但我认为在未来，我认为这种差异会大得多。我认为你会看到更多不同种类的公司，甚至新的模式和想法，
could just be so divergent from yours that it's very hard to understand their desire to be in the office or not have to come into the office. And then, you know, as Jason mentioned, I guess to like muddying it all is those things being forced to change or changing over time um anytime i think there's a change it's also uh difficult because people's ability to handle or deal with change can can vary and so um i think all of those make it a a topic that's not one size fits all but i do think there's some things to talk about that you know if they're if you're going to work from home full-time or part-time there are some i think things you can do
涌现出来。所以，你知道，我认为我们将以那种方式，希望会更好，因为你可以根据你的个人偏好进行选择。是的，这完全说得通。所以是的，我想也许我们应该从我们的背景开始。嗯……所以你知道我们俩都来自佛罗里达。我的家人最终搬到了德克萨斯州，你的家人还在佛罗里达，而我们当时在加利福尼亚，距离数千英里。而且我确实认为我们应该承认这很艰难。我的意思是，有很多这样做的人，这不是我们独有的问题。有些人的家人在地球的另一端，对吧？那更难。但……但……嗯，我认为你知道，当你有了孩子，然后试图抚养这些孩子，他们需要很多时间，你投入的时间越多，
to to be aware of to help yourself to to sort of think about it and i i do agree that there's a spectrum from you know remote work all remote work hybrid plans and i think going forward with high confidence i feel I can say they're all probably going to meet more diversity, more variance in the kinds of companies and jobs available than there was pre-COVID. Pre-COVID, it was almost always in office expectation for full five days a week or more. And very, very few companies were fully remote. But I think in the future, I think that variance will be a lot higher. I think you'll see a lot more different kinds of companies and even new models and ideas
他们拥有的那种培育……嗯……生活就越多。所以当然你真的被迫这样做。而且……嗯……所以这就是当你真正开始想要有更多家人在身边的时候。所以我认为它确实倾向于……在家工作的福利确实倾向于……嗯……年龄较大。然后另一方面，你知道，这很好……你知道，在你有了家庭或所有这些之前，去一个办公室很好……在你有了家庭或所有这些之前，去一个办公室很好，在那里你有……我们在有孩子之前去过一个办公室，在那里我们可以受益于有其他人在一起，以及那里发生的所有那种被动沟通，那种饮水机旁的闲聊，所有这些。所以绝对有，正如你所说，有很多不同的因素。
popping up. And so, you know, I think we'll have in that way that will hopefully be better because you can kind of choose based on your personal preferences. Yeah, that totally makes sense. So yeah, I think maybe we should start with kind of our background. um so you know both of us were uh from florida my family ended up moving to texas your family's still in florida and we were working uh you know thousands of miles away in california and i do think that we should just acknowledge that that's tough like i mean there's a lot of people who do it it's not uniquely our problem there's people whose families are on the other side of the planet right that's even harder um but but uh i think you know as you like have kids and then try and raise those kids they take a lot of time and the more time you put in the
我想就像在这里剧透结局一样，我认为我们确实必须采取一种相对主义的方法，说：“看，不同的人处于不同的情况。”公司只需要能够根据具体情况处理这些情况。所以像亚马逊正在做的那样，所有远程人员都被解雇，或者他们不能获得晋升，这样的笼统做法。或者在另一种情况下，走向另一个极端，我们不会为办公室付费。所以你永远不会有一个你可以去的地方，那是你工作的地方。所以，我的意思是，这是两个极端，我认为它们只是不会有帮助，不如找到一些中间地带。我想是的，我想你总结了基础和动机，关于家庭情况是导致我们最终……我们所处位置的关键原因。我确实认为对于纯软件公司或公司的一部分，与那些有
more sort of nurturing uh uh life that they have so of course you're really compelled to do that and uh and so that that's when you really start wanting to have more family around so i think that it does tend to the work from home benefits do tend to skew kind of uh older um and then on the flip side you know it's it's good uh you know before you have a family or any of that it's nice to go into an office where you have a family or any of that, it's nice to go into an office where you have, we went into an office before we had kids where we could benefit from like having other people around and just all the sort of passive communication that goes on there, the sort of water cooler chatter and all of that. So definitely there's, as you said, there's a lot of different factors.
物理或制造或商业组成部分的公司相比，是有话可说的。或者我的意思是，我认为它也可以是还原论的。我认为你和我大部分时间工作的地方都是拥有非常大型的纯软件组织或仅软件组织，而硬件集成组件很少的公司。所以这些事情可能与你知道的拥有生产线的公司非常不同。所以我认为从那种方式来看，很难有一个“一刀切”的方法，或者让人们理解两者的需求。然后就像你提到的，我确实同意，我认为在你职业生涯的早期，为了各种目的和指导以及那种东西而在身边有同志情谊，你的时间表里没有那么严格，在办公室里会有很大帮助。
I think like sort of spoiling the ending here, I think that we do have to take sort of a relativistic approach and say, look, like different people are in different situations. And the company just needs to be able to handle those situations on like a case by case basis. So blanket things like all remote people are fired, like what Amazon is doing, or they don't get promoted. Or on the other case, to the other extreme, we're not going to pay for an office. And so you will never have a place that you can go to that's your place to work. So, I mean, these are two extremes that I think are just not going to help not as helpful as finding some middle ground i think yeah i think you summed up the basis and motivations about family situations being a key reason i think for both of us of why of why the the situation ended up um where we did i do think there is something to be said for sort of software only companies or parts of the company versus companies that have
我确实同意这一点。而且我认为Facebook已经提出来并说了一些关于那个的事情，或者Meta，我猜，他们有一些，你知道，对初级工程师有一点点不同的处理方式，
a physical or manufacturing or business component or i mean i think it can also be reductionists like i think where you and i both have spent most of our time working are companies that had very large software only organizations or only software organizations and very little hardware integration components. And so those things can be very different than, you know, places that have manufacturing lines. And so I think from that way, it's also hard for a one size fits all approach or people to kind of understand the needs of both. And then like you do mention, I do agree that I think earlier in your sort of career, having camaraderie around for a variety of purposes and mentorship and that kind of stuff, there's less rigor in your schedule and it can help a lot to be in the office.
与更高级的工程师相比。而且，你知道，随着时间的推移，他们已经在这方面做了工作。所以我确实认为这些讨论有一些，你知道，价值。而且……而且我确实真的认为，但我还认为很多人没有意识到，当你……你处于在家工作状态时，那种内在动力，心理上，并且对自己非常诚实地说：“嘿，如果没人在这儿，就像当每个人都在
I do agree with that. And I think Facebook has come up and said some stuff about that or meta, I guess, where they had some, you know, a little bit of a different handling for junior engineers
周围时，有那种同伴压力，对吧？就像，嘿，即使你有一个目标，人们也在看着你工作，你也在看着别人工作。有一种深层的内在水平，就像‘我也应该，你知道，在工作’。”即使每个人都在办公室里玩耍或偷懒，那也是一种干扰。但看到每个人都在工作真的可以激励你也去工作。如果你在家，你能够做到吗？还是你会因为你生活中或你情况中正在发生的事情，或者外面的事情，或者噪音，或者去散步等等而分心，对吧？就像，无论发生什么，你真的能够坐下来专注吗？
versus more senior engineers. And, you know, over time, they've sort of worked on that. And so I do think there's some, you know, merit to those discussions. And've sort of worked on that. And so I do think there's some, uh, you know, merit to those, those discussions. And I, and I do really think that, but I also think a lot of people don't realize when you're, you're sort of work from home, that internal motivation, the psychologically and being really brutally honest with yourself and saying, Hey, if nobody's around, like when everybody's
或者，你知道，我还要说这很困难。即使，你知道，我在家工作，例如，这周有一个部分假期。即使，你知道，我在家工作，例如，这周有一个部分假期。我不知道你怎么称呼它。所以我当时在工作，但我的家人休息，有些人工作，有些人休息。这……这有点混合。所以我坐在电脑前。我的家人在外面做一些，你知道，或多或少有趣的事情，在房子周围，然后出去，告诉我，而我坐在这里试图完成我的工作，他们对我表示尊重，但我是否有足够的动力坚持下去并完成我需要做的事情，即使周围有这些干扰？如果你在办公室，那种动力对你来说就在那里，因为你在那里，对吧？就像……是的，有点与它隔绝了，你已经
around, there's that peer pressure, right? Like, Hey, even if you have an object, like people are kind of seeing you working, you're seeing other people working. There's like a deep internal level of like, I should also be, you know, working. And it can be true if everyone's just playing around or goofing off at the office. That's also a distraction. But seeing everybody work can be really motivating for you to do work as well. And if you're home, are you going to be able to do that? Or are you going to be distracted by the stuff in your life or your situation that are going on or the things outside or the noises or going for a walk or whatever, right? Like, are you actually going to be able to sit down and focus no matter what's
承诺了……相比之下，如果你坐在那里听到电子游戏的声音，或者听到你知道的事情发生，你是否仍然坐在那里，以同样的专注度敲击你的代码？还是你无法拥有那种内在动力，这是只有你自己才能回答的问题，而且对每个人来说都会不同。是的，是的，完全同意。好的，所以我认为我们做得很好，涵盖了它是什么，我们现在应该涵盖什么。所以你，你知道，如果你不在家工作，你将与在家工作的人一起工作。
going on? Or, you know, I will also say it is difficult. Even, you know, I work from home and for instance, this week there was a partial holiday. Even, you know, I work from home and for instance, this week there was a partial holiday. I don't know how you call it. So I was working, but like my family had off and some people work, some people had off. It was, it was sort of mixed. And so I was sitting at my computer. My family was off doing something, you know, more or less fun and around the house and then out and about and coming and telling, and I'm sitting here like attempting to get my work done and they were respectful to me but am I able to be motivated enough to stick with it and get what I need to do done even though those distractions around and if you're in an office that motivation is sort of there for you because you're there right like yeah kind of cut off from it you've
所以无论如何，理解在家工作的“该做”和“不该做”对你都有好处。如果你在管理人员，或者即使你是某位在家工作的人的同僚，这都可以帮助你，你总是可以提供这个建议，或者你可以建议他们听这个节目。嗯，但仅仅知道好坏，我认为这对这一点非常重要。嗯，所以……嗯，我们在列表上的第一件事是时间表。我认为这极其极其重要。嗯，一些一般的
already committed uh versus if you're sitting there and hearing video games being played or hearing you know stuff happening are you still sitting there and hearing video games being played or hearing you know stuff happening are you still sitting there and typing your code with the same focus uh or are you not able to have that internal motivation is something only you can answer and it's going to be different for everyone yep yep totally okay so i think we got we did a pretty good job covering what it is what we should cover now so you, you know, if you're not working from home, you're going to be working with people who are working from home.
我做过的事情，效果非常好，是……嗯，你知道，我终于……有点像给我的日历进行了颜色编码。我在我的日历里放了很多个人的事情。所以例如，如果我周五在家工作，并且我有意向……在周五抽一块牛胸肉，同时我在周五在家工作，并且我有意向在周五抽一块牛胸肉，同时我在家工作，这是一个好主意，强烈推荐。我实际上会设置微小的15分钟会议，比如：“好的，把牛胸肉拿出来，包好，放上苹果醋，或者其他什么。”就像如果你在想：“我会在在家工作时洗衣服，或者这些其他事情。”只是把它们明确出来。你知道，如果你羞于把这些事情放在每个人都能看到的日历上，你可以把它们设为私人会议。
And so it behooves you no matter what to understand the best, like the do's and don'ts of working from home. This can help you if you're managing people, or even if you're a peer to somebody who's working from home, you can always offer this advice, or you can suggest that they listen to the show. Uh, but just knowing goods and bads, I think are really important for this. Um, so, um, the first thing we have on the list is scheduling. I think that this is extremely extremely important um some kind of general
所以无论如何，了解在家办公的最佳做法，即该做什么和不该做什么，对你都有好处。如果你在管理人员，或者即使你只是在家办公的人的同事，你也可以随时提供这些建议，或者你可以建议他们听这个节目。呃，但仅仅了解好坏，我认为这对这一点非常重要。嗯，所以，呃，我们在清单上的第一件事是日程安排。我认为这非常非常重要，呃，某种通用的
things i've done that worked really well is um you know i did uh finally kind of like color code my calendar i put a bunch of personal things in my calendar so for example if i'm working from home on friday and i have an intent to to uh smoke a brisket on friday while i'm working from home on Friday and I have an intent to smoke a brisket on Friday while I'm working from home, which is a great idea, highly recommend it. I will actually set up tiny 15-minute meetings for like, okay, take the brisket out and wrap it and put apple cider vinegar on it or whatever. Like if you're thinking like, I'm going to do my laundry while I'm at working from home or these other things, just make them explicit. You know, if you're ashamed to like put these things on your calendar where everyone can see it, you can make them private meetings,
我做过的一些效果很好的事情是，呃，你知道，我终于给我的日历进行了颜色编码。我在日历中放入了很多个人事务，所以例如，如果我周五在家办公，并且我打算在周五工作时熏制一块牛胸肉，这是一个好主意，强烈推荐。我实际上会设置微小的15分钟会议，比如，好的，把牛胸肉拿出来，包好，涂上苹果醋之类的。如果你在想，比如，我要在在家办公时洗衣服，或者做其他这些事情，就把它们明确写出来。你知道，如果你不好意思把这些事情放在每个人都能看到的日历上，你可以把它们设为私人会议，
you know, so people don't have to see. I don't really care. So like sometimes I'll go to a meeting and they're like, how's that brisket coming? But, but I think being intentional about your time can just be transparent that part is less less less important but what is important is that you can look back and say yeah you know this this day you know i i uh i spoke some brisket i did some laundry i went for a run i did all these things but you know i worked from like nine to nine or something or 9 to 7. So I did the hours. I just took breaks in the middle and it works out. I think it's easy to fall into a trap where you start running a lot of errands and doing a lot of other things. And then at the end, you just don't know whether you really like put in enough time.
你知道，这样人们就不用看到了。我其实不在乎。所以有时候我去开会，他们会问，那个牛胸肉做得怎么样了？但是，我认为在时间安排上要有意为之，你可以坦诚地说那部分不太重要，但重要的是你能回顾过去并说，是的，你知道，这一天我烤了牛胸肉，洗了衣服，去跑步了，我做了所有这些事情，但你知道，我从九点工作到九点，或者九点到七点。所以我确实投入了时间。我只是在中间休息了一下，效果还不错。我认为很容易陷入一个陷阱，就是你开始忙于处理各种琐事，做很多其他事情。然后到最后，你根本不知道自己是否真的投入了足够的时间。
And I guess like a meta point, it doesn't really matter how much time you put in. What matters is getting your projects done, right? So you don't have to put in eight hours a day, but, but, but I think that it's all kind of connected.
我想这是一个元层面的观点，你投入多少时间其实并不重要。重要的是完成你的项目，对吧？所以你不必每天工作八小时，但是，我认为这一切都是相互关联的。
It's like, you can end up in a position where let's say a deadline slips, then you're going to kind of wonder, did I just not work as hard as I should have on this? And so that's where you go back to your calendar and say, like, oh, no, I actually was, you know, I did work a ton of hours, I just miscalculated how hard this project is. Versus, you know, when you're at work, you have this like, because you're driving to work and back, you have this like general sense of how much you're working
就像，你可能会陷入一种境地，比如截止日期延误了，然后你会怀疑，我是不是在这件事上没有付出应有的努力？这就是你回到日历查看的时候，你会说，哦，不，我实际上确实投入了大量时间，我只是误判了这个项目的难度。相比之下，当你在办公室工作时，因为你要开车往返，你对自己的工作量有一个大致的感知。
and when you're at home you lose that sense you have to replace it with something explicit i absolutely agree on this on the scheduling front and i think the reverse as well too is having a schedule with your family as well so that it is a mutual respect thing like hey from this time to this time like you're gonna see me i'm around but i'm i'm i'm not here like this is this is time i'm dedicated but then there's also times when i'm not and so i'm not doing work in this block and this is family time and you know it's the end of the day so that you don't end up accidentally working you know 14 15 16 hour days because you just didn't plan otherwise.
而当你待在家里时，你会失去那种感知，你必须用明确的东西来替代它。我完全同意在日程安排方面这一点，而且我认为反过来也一样，就是也要和家人制定日程，这样是一种相互尊重。比如，从这个时间到那个时间，你会看到我，我在附近，但我并不在这里，这是我专注工作的时间。但也有我不工作的时候，这段时间我不处理工作，这是家庭时间，你知道，这是在一天结束的时候，这样你就不会因为没有计划而意外地工作了14、15、16个小时。
And I do think you got to try to strike that balance or even just burn burnout. And so I think scheduling is important on both fronts. I also think scheduling is maybe a bit more of a important topic and making sure that you connect with team members that you need to. And really, even if it's not going into a meeting, scheduling that, like, hey, I'm going to have a email conversation or Slack or connect with this person and do this thing because there's no, oh, I'll just do it when I see them because you won't see them, right? Like, you're not going to bump into them. So those things have to uh sort of planned and and sort of thought through and i think that it can be a bit we were having this i was explaining to someone what crm software
我确实认为你必须努力达到那种平衡，否则就会导致倦怠。所以我认为在两个方面进行日程安排都很重要。我还认为日程安排可能是一个更重要的话题，要确保你与需要联系的团队成员保持沟通。真的，即使不是去开会，也要安排好，比如，嘿，我要进行一次电子邮件交流或Slack沟通，或者与这个人联系做这件事，因为没有那种“哦，我见到他们时再做吧”的机会，因为你根本见不到他们，对吧？你不会偶然碰到他们。所以这些事情必须以某种方式计划好，并经过深思熟虑。我觉得这可能有点……我们当时正在讨论，我正在向某人解释什么是CRM软件。
was because they were like oh i don't even know what salesforce is this huge company and they're do crm and i don't even know what crm is that's explained to me like oh that sounds dumb that's just a spreadsheet and i was like wow okay whatever uh but but this part one part of it is managing your relationships with other people at work and building up maybe that's talking very condensed about work stuff but maybe it's also having casual time to to connect with people and understand who they are and sort of like build up that that rapport with people um and it has to become intentional and so scheduling those things as well um i think can be a bit weird at first but it's definitely important yeah i totally totally agree i think um you know looking back so and i
因为他们说，哦，我甚至不知道Salesforce是什么，这是一家大公司，他们做CRM，我甚至不知道CRM是什么，给我解释一下。我说，哦，那听起来很蠢，那不就是个电子表格吗？我说，哇，好吧，随便吧。但这一部分，其中一部分是管理你在工作中与他人的关系，建立……也许这谈论工作内容太简略了，但也许也包括有休闲时间与人交流，了解他们是谁，并建立那种融洽的关系。这必须是有意为之的，所以安排这些事情，起初可能会觉得有点奇怪，但绝对很重要。是的，我完全同意。我想，你知道，回顾过去，而且我
think we've kind of like uh foreshadowed this but you know i found working from home personally to be really difficult i wasn't like i mean the work got done but i feel like i didn't you know communicate uh as often i just i just didn't build the same relationships so like when i look back at my work from home time um you know i still have closer relationships to people that i worked with in person before the pandemic um and so i've spent the past two months working in person two three months and uh i feel like i have a closer relationship to some of these people um than people i worked with remotely for much longer and again it's this is a spectrum so uh if you worked with me remotely and we're close friends and we talk all the time on on sms this is obviously not directed to you uh but but
想我们已经预示了这一点，但我个人发现居家办公真的很难。我并不是说工作没完成，但我感觉我没有像以前那样频繁地沟通，我只是没有建立起同样的关系。所以当我回顾居家办公的那段时间，我仍然与疫情前在办公室共事的人保持着更亲密的关系。所以我过去两三个月一直在办公室工作，我感觉我和其中一些人的关系比我远程共事了更久的人还要亲密。再说一次，这是一个光谱，所以如果你曾与我远程共事，我们是好朋友，经常发短信聊天，这显然不是针对你的，但是
just in aggregate i feel like i didn't develop as many as close relationships and and i think a big part of that was uh just not being again explicit so just you know especially uh especially with people above me in the chart you know i i never really felt comfortable setting up a meeting with my boss to just talk about the weather like that never really felt okay or even like my boss's peers or even other peers who are higher level than me. And so because of that, I didn't really build any of those relationships. And the relationships I did build remotely were, you know, people who like either reported to me or were like kind of reported to my peers, etc.
总的来说，我觉得我没有建立起那么多亲密的关系。我认为很大一部分原因就是没有做到“明确”。特别是对于职级比我高的人，我从来没有觉得可以随意约老板开个会只是聊聊天气，那感觉不太合适，甚至对老板的同事，或者其他职级比我高的人也是如此。正因为如此，我并没有真正建立起那些关系。而我远程建立的关系，要么是向我汇报的人，要么是向我的同事汇报的人等等。
So I do feel like you have to get out of your comfort zone and uh understand like yeah you know my boss is definitely busier and has more responsibility than i do that's why he's my boss but uh but that doesn't mean that you won't take like 15 minutes to just talk about the weather over zoom that was that was i think in hindsight i kind of like a mistake that I made. But, and then Patrick, I think you've been working remote, you know, same time I have, but you're still working remote. I think you've found, you've really thrived remotely. Yeah.
所以我确实觉得你必须走出舒适区，理解这一点。是的，我知道我的老板肯定比我更忙，责任更大，这就是他成为我老板的原因，但这并不意味着你不能花15分钟在Zoom上聊聊天气。事后看来，我觉得那是我犯的一个错误。但是，帕特里克，我想你一直在远程工作，和我时间差不多，但你还在远程工作。我想你发现自己非常适合远程工作。是的。
I mean, I think for me, so you, we should say, I guess you started working remote at a company, you moved to a new company where you were more or less remote, and then you've kind of moved on. So I've been at the same company the whole time. So I think maybe I'm a bit rose-colored glasses because I had built a lot of those relationships ahead of time and then brought them remote with me. So I haven't had to rebuild them. I had rapport with almost all of the people um that i work with and even even my management i do think you have a great point though that people should be aware of is being very careful in hybrid situations if you're remote and other people are on site especially if you imagine a manager that's on site and has some people that are remote and some
我的意思是，对于我来说，我们应该说，我想你是在一家公司开始远程工作的，你搬到了一家新公司，在那里你或多或少是远程的，然后你又换了工作。所以我一直待在同一家公司。所以我认为我可能戴着玫瑰色眼镜，因为我提前建立了很多关系，然后把它们带到了远程工作中。所以我不需要重建它们。我和我共事的所有人，甚至包括我的管理层，都有很好的融洽关系。但我确实认为你提出了一个很好的观点，人们应该意识到，在混合办公的情况下要非常小心。如果你是远程的，而其他人是在现场的，特别是如果你想象一个在现场的经理，他手下有一些人是远程的，而有些人
people are there is uh i think there's a natural uh sort of difference that can build up there and some managers may be very good at sort of handling that and others may not be and you just got to be real realizing that like jason's saying like you need to make sure that you're intentional about building rapport that people on site wouldn't need to be is that fair or unfair well like i tell my kid it doesn't matter life's not like it doesn't need to be. Is that fair or unfair? Well, like I tell my kids, it doesn't matter. Life's not, it doesn't need to be fair or unfair. It's just the way it is. And you can either realize it or not.
是在现场的，我认为这之间会产生一种自然的差异。有些经理可能非常擅长处理这种情况，而另一些则不然。你只需要意识到，就像杰森说的，你需要确保你有意地去建立融洽关系，而现场的人则不需要这样做。这公平吗？还是不公平？嗯，就像我告诉我的孩子，这不重要，生活不是……它不需要公平或不公平。这只是现状。你可以选择意识到这一点，也可以选择不意识到。
It's your choice, I guess. But spoiler, it's the way it is, is you're going to maybe have to be intentional about some things that aren't. And that goes into, if that's part of why you don't like it, yeah, that's fair. Oh, that's different.
这是你的选择，我想。但剧透一下，现状就是你可能必须对某些事情有意为之。如果这就是你不喜欢它的原因，是的，那很公平。哦，那不一样。
You said the word fair. Anyways, but yeah, I think that the, you're absolutely right. of why you don't like it yeah that's fair um oh that's different use of the word fair anyways um but yeah i think that the you're absolutely right like building those those relationships is critical and i think it feeds into everyone's talk about next it's just communications and i think if you're uh for companies that are fully remote you know comes like obviously i really got to figure it out um but remote work also generally comes with people in different time zones or different schedules that are even more divergent than being in the office. And so I think figuring out a culture around your most people have now sort of the the meetings, the sort of Zoom, Microsoft Teams, WebEx, whatever, you know, video conferencing, there's email, you know, and then there's some
你用了“公平”这个词。总之，是的，我认为你是完全正确的。建立那些关系至关重要，我认为这引出了大家接下来要谈的话题，那就是沟通。我认为如果你是……对于完全远程的公司，你知道，显然我真的得搞清楚这一点。但远程工作通常也伴随着人们处于不同的时区或不同的时间表，这比在办公室工作更加分散。所以我认为围绕你的……大多数人现在都有某种会议，那种Zoom、Microsoft Teams、WebEx，无论什么视频会议，还有电子邮件，然后还有一些
instant messaging kind of thing, whether you do that over text or Slack or the Teams product or whatever, right? People Discord, people have these sort of like, I guess, three modalities, as well as sort of wiki page editing or whatever. And I think figuring out the right way to communicate what you're working on, what your availability kind of is, communicating where you leave off on something if you're working on, what your availability kind of is, communicating where you leave off on something if you're handing it off or what you need people to do or how like what you're looking for help with or, you know, hey, I need this, you know, PR to be reviewed, whatever those kind of things are and being very, you know, deliberate about all of your communication or the very vast majority of
即时通讯之类的东西，无论你是通过短信、Slack还是Teams产品等等，对吧？人们使用Discord，人们有这三种模式，以及维基页面编辑之类的。我认为找出正确的方式来沟通你正在做的事情，你的可用性是什么，沟通如果你在处理某事时在哪里停下，如果你要交接工作，或者你需要别人做什么，或者你正在寻求什么帮助，或者，嘿，我需要这个PR被审查，无论这些是什么，并且非常审慎地对待你所有的沟通，或者绝大多数
your communication becomes written as opposed to casual in person. I'll just, when I see them, I'll tell them. And as someone who continues to work remote, despite working with people who are in a more hybrid situation, it's kind of funny to hear people say that, right? Like, oh, I'll just tell them when I see them. And it's like, okay, but for me, that's, that's like, I might have a meeting scheduled with them, you know, once a week or that they're in the share, but otherwise I'm not going to see them. So to me, if I need to tell someone something, I have to type it right now, like, or, you know, plan to type it because otherwise, you know, that communication won't take place. And so I think just across all of those things, finding the right way that people are aware of the work
你的沟通变成了书面形式，而不是随意的面对面交流。我只会说，“等我见到他们时，我会告诉他们。”作为一个继续远程工作的人，尽管与处于混合办公状态的人共事，听到人们这么说还是挺有趣的，对吧？比如，“哦，我见到他们时会告诉他们。”然后我想，好吧，但对我来说，这就像，我可能每周和他们安排一次会议，或者他们就在那里，但除此之外我见不到他们。所以对我来说，如果我需要告诉某人某事，我必须现在就打字，或者计划去打字，否则那种沟通就不会发生。所以我认为在所有这些事情上，找到正确的方式让人们了解你正在做的工作
that you're doing so that there's not a conflict to be resolved, right? Like making sure there's no overlap or we're doing the same thing. So being intentional about communicating what you're doing, when you're doing it, how the work is getting done. And it's, I found there are some people that I work with are very good about expressing their status over, you know, in team rooms or in personal messages proactively. And then other people really have to be sort of prodded to give a sort of update. And as if you are the person who's in a remote day or remote, you know, working situation permanently, I think making sure to be proactive about communicating what you're doing and what you're working on so that not that like people like
这样就不会有需要解决的冲突，对吧？比如确保没有重叠，或者我们没有在做同样的事情。所以要刻意地沟通你正在做什么，什么时候做，工作是如何完成的。我发现我共事的一些人非常擅长主动在团队聊天室或个人消息中表达他们的状态。而其他人则真的需要被催促才能给出更新。如果你是一个长期处于远程工作状态的人，我认为确保主动沟通你正在做的事情和你正在处理的任务非常重要，这样人们就不会觉得
jason you know it's not getting your 40 hours in it's just like that people are aware that you're there and the tasks that you're taking on and that they feel they know situationally where you are and that's something you have to to sort of pursue yourself yep yep totally agree um i think um you said something that really stuck with me um too much oh the uh the uh yeah the whole like i'll see them you know i'll just tell them when i see them i think that another important thing there is to keep notes because you know you can't really there's certain things that like aren't practical to do immediately like for example the example you have is perfect where you know it's not just something i can text somebody it's something that requires like a
杰森，你知道，这不是为了凑够你的40小时，只是让人们意识到你在那里，以及你正在承担的任务，让他们在情境上知道你在哪里，这是你必须自己去追求的事情。是的，完全同意。我想你说的某件事真的让我印象深刻，那个“我会见到他们时告诉他们”的观点。我认为另一个重要的事情是记笔记，因为你知道，有些事情确实不适合立即处理。比如你举的例子就很完美，它不仅仅是我可以发短信给某人的事情，它需要像
face-to-face conversation um but it's not practical for me to uh just set up a zoom call right now with some person because who knows what they're doing like you would like in person you could just walk over and say hey blah blah um but over zoom like it's a little bit more challenging because uh the person might not even get your your zoom invite in time if you did it for five minutes from now right so what i did instead is which i which i thought was a really useful and i've carried this over even to when i work in the office is just keep notes um you know i use a remarkable pad um but you could also use uh you know a kindle scribe or you could use uh google docs it doesn't have to be a physical thing paper and pencil i haven't heard of this thing but apparently some new invention um but yeah just keep notes i think that's important and and that
面对面的谈话，但现在立刻和某人安排Zoom通话并不现实，因为谁知道他们在做什么。就像在办公室，你可以走过去说，嘿，巴拉巴拉。但在Zoom上，这有点挑战性，因为如果你提前五分钟发邀请，对方可能根本来不及收到。所以我所做的是，我觉得非常有用，即使在我去办公室工作时也沿用了这个习惯，那就是记笔记。我用的是Remarkable平板，但你也可以用Kindle Scribe，或者Google Docs，不一定非要是纸和笔。我没听说过这个东西，但这显然是个新发明。但是的，记笔记，我认为这很重要。
um um and that way you know when you do meet with somebody you have like four things that you can cover and so um you know it ends up being more efficient. Yeah, absolutely. I think I use a notebook and pencil. I don't know. I don't know. Half the time, I don't think I ever go back and even look at what I wrote or be able to make sense of it. But just helping you and jotting down, like you said, a few notes about things.
这样当你和某人见面时，你有四件事可以涵盖，所以它最终会更有效率。是的，绝对。我想我用的是笔记本和铅笔。我不知道，有一半时间，我觉得我从来没有回头看我写了什么，或者根本看不懂。但就像你说的，记下几点关于事情的笔记确实有帮助。
I do think there is a culture in office as well, just to be balanced about it, where some people are more okay being interrupted, others less so. And this is for a variety of reasons, but you can kind of read people, you know, like see, like, do they look like they're really busy or do they look like they get interrupting? But it's a difficult problem. like i have a certain priority of thing that i need they have a certain desire or lack of desire to talk right now and like this is unspoken but it is a non-verbal communication in person uh that that sort of happens and needs to be normalized there uh online it's like you said it may like people don't know like am i just sitting doing
我确实认为办公室里也有一种文化，为了平衡起见，有些人更愿意被打断，有些人则不然。这有各种各样的原因，但你可以观察人们，比如，他们看起来真的很忙吗，还是看起来可以被打断？但这是一个难题。我有我需要处理的优先事项，他们有现在想谈或不想谈的愿望，这虽然没有明说，但它是面对面交流中的一种非语言沟通，需要在那边常态化。在线上，就像你说的，人们不知道，比如我是在写代码，还是在做培训，他们是否可以随时找我？我很乐意暂停一下和他们谈谈。
code am i just doing training and they are free to ping me i'm happy to pause it and talk to them um you know it's really difficult people don't know you know kind of what you're doing and so i try to express to people hey for me if you want to meet with me you know again here are the hours i'm generally available so you can generally expect me to be available within this time, but I might have meetings. So just send me a message and say, hey, I want to chat. And then I'll either tell you, yeah, let's do it now.
这真的很难，人们不知道你在做什么。所以我尽量向人们表达，嘿，对我来说，如果你想和我开会，同样，这是我通常有空的时间，所以你通常可以预期我在这个时间内有空，但我可能有会议。所以只需给我发个消息说，嘿，我想聊聊。然后我会告诉你，好的，现在就聊，或者，嘿，这是我下次有空的时间。你永远不应该因为询问而感到不好意思，因为我也不会因为拒绝你而感到不好意思。或者“现在不行”，或者“这是我下次有空的时间”。他们不应该觉得……要非常明确地告诉他们，嘿，你见不到我，所以直接问我就行了，大多数时候我都能抽出时间来和他们谈。是的，当然。还有，安排一些社交活动，这也是我会归类为沟通的事情。你知道，当我还在办公室时，通常组织领导，比如总监，无论谁，都会设定
Or like, hey, here's the next time I can kind of do it. And that you should never feel bad about asking because I won't feel bad about telling you no. And or not now, or here's the next time I can do it. And that they shouldn't feel like making it very clear hey you can't see me so just ask me and you know most of the time i'm able to to make time to talk to them yeah definitely also you know setting up uh kind of like social things that's another kind of thing i would put under communication um you know when when i was in person usually the org uh leader you know the director whoever would set um some kind of event
某种活动，比如“哦，今天是塔可周二，我要去订一千个塔可，或者200个塔可给整个组织”，或者“嘿，今天是这一天，或者周四我们来玩桌游，无论是什么”。但在网上，当你远程工作时，我认为你可能必须是那个发起活动的人。拥有那种社交时间很重要，而且它或多或少遵循与面对面相同的规则，不是每个人都必须去参加塔可周二。你可以继续在办公桌前工作，你不需要参加。我的意思是，我不建议那样做，我认为社交实际上非常重要。但我的意思是，没有强制要求去参加塔可周二。同样，也没有强制要求加入社交Zoom通话去玩网络刽子手游戏或其他小游戏。
like oh it's taco tuesday i'm gonna go and order a thousand taco or i don't know 200 tacos for like the entire org um and uh or you know hey this is uh this day or let's do you know board games on thursday or whatever it is um but online uh when you're working remote you know i think you might have to be the person to set that up um and it's important to have that kind of social time um and and it follows more or less the same rules as in person where not everyone has to go to Taco Tuesday. You could continue to work at your desk. You don't need to do that. I mean, I wouldn't recommend that. I think socializing is actually really important. But I'm saying you don't mandate, there's no mandate to go to Taco Tuesday. And similarly, there's no mandate to hop on a social Zoom call and play like Web Hangman or something or some little fun game.
所以你不要把它变成强制性的，但我认为为人们提供那个空间非常重要。是的，我完全同意。然后我认为我们要涵盖的最后一个主要事情是，如果你要进行混合办公或居家办公，我认为规划你工作的空间非常重要。我的意思是，那种“我只是在沙发上工作”或者“我只是在任何地方工作”的想法。有时我也会那样做，但这非常罕见。我认为拥有一个专门的空间要好得多，即使你去其他地方工作，你至少可以有一个让你专注的地方，你的大脑知道这是专注的地方，你去那里，那就是你专注的地方。
So you don't make it mandatory, but I think having that space for people is really important. Yep, I completely agree um and then the i think the last major thing we wanted to cover is uh if you're going to be doing hybrid work or work from home i mean i think planning your space you're going to do the work in is is very important i mean i think that there's this like oh i'm going to just do my work from the couch or i'm going to, you know, just be wherever. And sometimes I do that, but it's very rare. I think that it's a lot better to have a dedicated space that, you know, even if you go work from those other places, you can at least, you know, have the place that you go to focus and your brain knows this is the focus place and you go there and that's where you focus.
它可能在其他时间被用于其他用途，但在你居家办公的日子里，或者如果你一直居家办公，也许它是一个永久的设置。再说一次，就像我开头提到的，取决于人们的生活状况，这对他们来说可能更容易或更难。但对我来说，拥有这个办公桌非常重要。我花时间把它打造成我想要的样子，我们可以谈谈其中一些细节。但当我坐在这里做这件事时，我总是不得不逗逗家里的人，我的家人，就像
And it may be a space that's used for other stuff at other times, but during the days that you're working from home, or if you're working from home all the time, maybe it's a permanent setup. And again, like I mentioned in the beginning, depending on people's life situation, there may be a lot easier or harder for them. But for me, it's been very important to have, this is my desk. I've spent time trying to curate it into the the way i want and we can maybe talk about some of what that that is but um when when i'm sitting here doing this and i always have to you know tease the people to people in the house with my family is like
如果你听到我在键盘上噼里啪啦地打字，那不是随意问我事情的时候，你知道，无论什么，也许等一下。但我认为拥有这些东西非常关键。是的，完全同意。我的意思是，我经历过一段时期，基本上在四点钟，孩子们会开始砰砰地敲门，想进来玩电子游戏。所以我们把所有的电子游戏都放在我工作的同一个房间里，这很……棘手。是的，这不是个好主意，因为孩子们想玩游戏，而我们在工作日每天给他们半小时的游戏时间。所以，如果他们早点来，他们也不会得到更多时间，但当然，他们总是想尽快玩，对吧？
if you hear me clackety clackety clackety on my keyboard like that's not the time to just ask me casually something you know whatever like yeah maybe wait um but i think having those those things is is very critical yeah totally i mean i went through a period where basically um like at four o'clock the kids would start like banging on the door to want to come in and play video games so so we have all of the video games in the same room that i do all my work in which is uh spicy yeah not not a good idea because because you know the kids want to play games and we give them like a half an hour a day during the week of of game time um so so uh it's not like they get more time if they come earlier but of course they just really want to do it as soon as possible, right?
所以这造成了一种奇怪的情况，我会开始妥协，说，好吧，四点钟，我要去那个房间用笔记本电脑工作。但那样并不舒服，而且你失去了语境。所以最后我意识到，好吧，不，从几点到五点，办公室是禁区，我必须专注。这让事情变得更容易了。我完全同意，如果能做到的话，拥有一个专门的空间是非常重要的。是的，所以当人们去办公室时，通常……这可能会有所不同，有些人会得到居家办公的津贴，很多人没有。但在办公室，你通常会得到键盘、显示器之类的东西。但在家里，这不一定是真的。但我不知道，我现在的设置可能比在办公室时还要好。但我有一个站立式办公桌，尽管我绝大多数时间都是坐着的，但至少它可以微调到我想要的高度。我可以站起来。所以我有一个不错的站立式办公桌，我的显示器放在显示器支架上，所以下面的桌面很整洁。我认为拥有那个空间，只是……我不知道，也许其他人会说，不，我真的不在乎。
So that just creates this weird situation where I would start acquiescing and saying, okay, at four, I'm going to go work in this fair room on my laptop. But then it's not very comfortable and you kind of lost your context. And so finally i realized like okay no uh you know from you know whatever until five o'clock uh you know the the office is off limits like i have to focus and uh that made things easier i totally agree having a dedicated space is is huge if you could do it yeah and so i mean when people go to the office generally and and this can vary some people get stipends for uh you know an allowance for setting up their home office many people don't um but you
但我有音箱，因为我在家里不需要戴耳机。所以我桌上有音箱，以适当的音量听音乐，既保护耳朵又音质不错。还有一个摄像头用来处理我的事情。把一切都设置得很好，而且在同一个地方。所以每次我去开会，我知道东西在哪里，我有我需要的东西，我知道我要做什么。
know in the office you often are provided you know keyboard monitor that kind of stuff um but at home you know that's not necessarily true but i don't know i i still probably have better setup than i probably did at the office. But you know, I have a standing sitting desk, even though I sit the vast majority of the time, but at least it's sort of micro adjusted to where I want. And I can stand up. And so I have a nice standing sitting desk, I have my computer up on or my monitor up on a monitor arm. So the desk underneath it is nice and clean. And I think having that space that just, I don't know, maybe other people are like, no, I'm not really, I don't really care.
但是，是的，我确实买了一把好椅子。我想很多人用的办公椅都很烂，但是……哦，等等，真的吗？等等，多告诉我一些。因为我绝对属于那种觉得椅子很烂的人，但什么才算是一把好椅子？对我来说，是可以调节的。
But I have speakers because I don't need headphones in my home. So I have speakers set on my desk to listen to music at a appropriately ear sensitive volume, but still sounding good, a webcam for doing my, my stuff. Um, and having it all set up really nicely and in the same spot. So every time when I go into a meeting, like I know where things are, I have the stuff I need, I know what I'm going to do.
我不会深入探讨这个非常极客的话题，但我的意思是，你去Reddit上看看，会看到很多人们推荐的常见款式，办公室也经常关闭。我个人，当我在办公室时，我总是坐在会议室里。
Um, but yeah, and I have a, I did get a nice chair. I think a lot of people have really crappy office chairs, but, uh, Oh, wait, really? Wait, tell me more about this. Cause I, I'm definitely in this camp where I think I have a crappy chair, but like, how do you, what actually makes a chair good? For me, it's one that's like adjustable.
那里有随机的人坐在椅子上，从来没困扰过我。所以对我来说，购买清算的办公家具，你可以在eBay上找到，价格只有20%，也就是8折，或者大多数中等规模的城市都有办公清算仓库，我就是从那里买的椅子。你可以进去试坐。所以有像赫尔曼·米勒（Herman Miller）那样的椅子，人们真的很喜欢，它们可以定制，非常舒适。可调节座椅高度、座椅深度、腰部支撑。我住的地方在佛罗里达，非常热，所以我用的是网背椅子，没有垫子，这样有空气流通，我的背部不会出汗。但
I'm not going to like go in, it's a really nerdy deep topic, but I mean, you go on the sort of Reddit and see a lot of common ones that people are suggesting and offices close all the time. I personally, I mean, and when I was in the office, I sat in conference rooms all the time i personally i mean and when i was in the
所有这些对我来说都很重要，要非常舒适，否则我会背痛。这又回到了锻炼的问题，你必须确保锻炼，但也要有一把舒适的椅子，因为你要在那里待很长时间。在办公室，如果你有会议，你通常会从一个会议室移动到另一个会议室。而在家里，很容易坐下来，然后一天中绝大部分时间都不离开椅子，对吧？所以你坐在同一个地方的时间比在办公室还要长。拥有那些刻意的起身走动的时间实际上很重要。但拥有一把舒适的椅子，因为你要在那里待更久，在我看来，或者至少对我来说，我在那里待的时间更长，这超级重要。是的，这很有道理。另一件我会
office i sat in conference rooms all the time and that had random people sitting in the chairs and never bothered me so for me buying liquidated office furniture which you can find on ebay um for like 20 of the price you know like 80 off or most cities of a decent size have like office liquidation warehouses which is where i got my chairs from you can go in and sit in them um and so there's like you know herman miller chairs that that people really like and they can be customized and be very nice but adjustable seat height adjustable seat depth adjustable you know like lumbar support uh and where i live it's very hot in florida so i have mesh backed chairs so there's no like cushion so that there's airflow and i don't get a sweaty back um but you
列入清单的事情是去户外。我注意到，当我居家办公时，你知道，好吧，我的总体策略我在节目中谈过很多次，但简单回顾一下，就是我在工作日会投入大量时间。如果事情变得忙碌，我会投入越来越多的时间，但周末是绝对禁区。除非真的着火了，发生了重大灾难，否则我周末绝不工作。但正因为如此，周一我会带着很多事情进来，我会工作到周二或周三，在周三左右的某个时候，我会意识到我已经有70个小时没出过门了，这简直失控了。所以，是的，我推荐的一件事是，做一次“假装骑车上班”，或者骑车五英里，然后回到家，但这就像你的“骑车上班”，或者做点什么，让你在户外待一会儿。我很幸运，办公室里有充足的自然光。所以并不是说我没见过太阳之类的。但我认为在户外非常重要。即使你在周末做了很多有趣的事情，我认为在工作日抽出时间去散步，做点什么让你在户外待一会儿，依然很重要。所以你的意思是你需要“接触草地”？每天接触草地，而不是你桌上的奇亚宠物。那不算。那是作弊。那是奇亚宠物。
know all those things are are important to me uh to be really comfortable else i get back pain um which goes back to the exercising um you got to make sure you exercise but also have having a comfortable chair because you're going to be there a lot and in the office you often move meeting to meeting if you have meetings and generally move at home it's very easy to sit down and then not like leave your chair uh for for vast majority of the day right so you're sitting in the same spot even more than in the office and having those intentional get up and walk around times is actually actually important but but having a nice chair to sit in because you're going to be there longer in my opinion or at least for me i was there longer uh is super important yeah that makes sense another thing that i would
不，我同意。我认为在个人方面，正如你提到的，我有时会反思我上次……所以我确实会像你说的去户外一点点。但上次我去一个不是我家的地方是什么时候？有时可能是……我不会承认有多久，可能是一个非常长的时间。我对此没意见。但周围的人会问我，我还好吗？如果他们发现了或者意识到我没去过任何地方，比如，“嘿，你已经好几天没去过任何地方了，你还好吗？”哦，是的，我很好。我在这里有很多事情要做。就像你提到的，我锻炼。所以我跑步。我在户外跑步。我在户外，但我不会
put on the list is uh is going outside i noticed that like uh when i work from home like you know like okay so general my general strategy i've talked about this on the show many times, but just to recap, is I'll work a ton of hours during the week. Like if, if, if things get busy, I will put more and more and more hours during the week, but the weekends are totally off limits. Like I'm only going to work on the weekend if something's truly on fire, there's like a major disaster. Um, but because of that, like, like yeah i'll come in on monday it'll be a lot to do i'll work monday or tuesday or wednesday and at some point around wednesday i'll realize like i haven't left the house in like 70 hours or something and it'll just be out of control and so um and so yeah one thing i would recommend is is uh um you know do like a fake
一定要去其他地方。就像你说的，当你工作时，你倾向于开车上班和下班，这至少是一件事。但你也会倾向于，至少我曾经这样做，在回家的路上顺便停一下，如果你需要从商店买什么东西。而对我来说，我不知道，是的，如果你能送货上门，你可以……我有其他人会更多地外出，所以我妻子会去买东西。但我确实认为，就像你说的，让你的大脑时不时去别的地方对你很重要。是的，我的意思是，与此相关，我发现非常有用的另一件事是去参加不同类型的聚会和活动，基本上合成地创造那种“饮水机聊天”。
bike to work or something where you bike for like five miles and you just end up back at home but like it's it's like your bike to work you know or do do something where you uh spend some time outside i am fortunate in that i get a lot of natural light in the office. So it's not like I'm not seeing the sun or anything like that. But I think being outside is super important. And even if you're there on the weekends doing a lot of fun stuff, I think it's still important during the week to just take some time, go for a walk, do something where you're going to be outside. So what you're saying is you need to touch grass? Touch grass every day and not like a chia pet on your desk. That doesn't count. That's cheating. That's a cheetah pet.
这有点奇怪，因为不是你的同事，而是其他科技人员，他们大概在其他公司工作，除非你碰巧有同事在附近去同一个聚会。但它给了你……有时你只需要和一群人在一起，聊聊某个话题，吃点披萨。所以你可以通过在你工作的城市找到志同道合的科技人员来获得同样的能量。我认为我们涵盖了很多家庭设置的内容。你知道，我肯定，无论好坏，并没有真正投入太多关注。我想我确实有一件事，是一个笔记本电脑支架，所以笔记本电脑屏幕更高。我发现那样会让我有点驼背。所以我确实认为把屏幕调整到正确的视线高度会保护你的背部。我认为
No, I agree. I think in the personal thing, as you mentioned, I sometimes will take account of when was the last time I... So I do go outside a little bit to your point to that level. But when was the last time I went somewhere that wasn't just my house? And sometimes it can be, I won't admit to how long, it can be a very long amount of time. And I'm okay with that. But people around me ask, am I okay? If they figure it out or realize I haven't gone anywhere, but like, hey, you haven't been anywhere in a certain amount of days or whatever. Are you okay? Oh, yeah, fine. I have plenty to do here or whatever. And like you mentioned, I exercise. So I do running. So I run outside. I'm out in the outdoors, but I won't
这很重要。哦，那你的设置呢？我会谈谈我的设置，然后你可以告诉我你的，因为我觉得你的可能好得多。但我有我的游戏台式机，我的工作笔记本电脑连接到相同的周边设备，相同的键盘、鼠标、显示器等。我从来没搞定KVM切换器，我想我买了一个，然后退回给亚马逊了。所以我现在有的是一个DisplayPort分配器和一个USB切换器，所以我必须按两个按钮，这有点烦人。但如果你操作得当，你实际上可以同时按下两个按钮。基本上我按一个按钮，它就切换到我的笔记本电脑DisplayPort，按另一个按钮，我的笔记本电脑现在就
necessarily go anywhere else and like you said when you're at work you tend to drive to work and drive home that's at least a thing but you also tend to at least i did stop on the way home sometimes if you need something from the store or whatever versus for me i don't know yeah if you could get it delivered you can you know i have other folks who are out and about more so my wife will pick stuff up or whatever but i do think like you said it's important for your brain to go somewhere else from time to time yeah i mean kind of related to that um one thing that that i found really useful was to go to different kinds of meetups and different events um and basically create synthetically that kind of water cooler chat
控制鼠标、键盘、摄像头等等。然后当我想回去时，我再按一次按钮。所以我发现这非常有用，因为你可以得到一个不错的人体工程学设置，并将其用于两件事。我的意思是，我想这取决于情况。我确实有一段时间的设置和你描述的非常相似。实际上，几乎一模一样。但我现在的设置是，我有两张完全相同的桌子并排摆放。所以我的游戏和家庭PC在同一张桌子上，同一把椅子，但不是同一个显示器。
where um you know it's it's a bit like strange because like not your co-workers it's other tech people who work for presumably other companies unless you happen to have co-workers nearby who are going to the same meetup um but you know it gives you that sometimes you just need to like be with a group of people with some kind of topic and just kind of talking and grabbing some pizza. And so you can kind of get that same kind of energy by finding like-minded tech people in whatever city you happen to be working in. um i think we covered a lot of home setup stuff you know i definitely for better or for worse don't really like pay a lot of attention i guess one thing i do have is um a laptop stand so the laptop screen is higher i was finding that was kind of like you know more hunched over um so i do think getting the screen at the right eye level will save your back i think
我的工作显示器稍微大一点，稍微好一点。我有一个笔记本电脑支架，我实际上把iPad放在上面，这是我用来进行视频会议的设备。所以它是一个定制的设备，无论我在后台编译什么或做什么，我的视频运行都很流畅。但是的，我有两个并排的设置，非常相似但不完全相同。我使用分体式键盘，分体式机械键盘，而普通的台式机是一个连体的，因为不是每个人都经历过那种长时间坐在那里，并确保找到正确的打字习惯。所以其他人会使用那台电脑，我是唯一一个
that's important um and uh oh what about like how do you so i'll tell i'll talk about my setup but then you can tell me yours because i'm feeling yours is probably way better um but what i have is i have my uh gaming desktop and i have my work laptop hooked up to the same peripherals you know same keyboard mouse you know monitor etc and so i never quite got the whole kvm thing to work i think i bought one and then returned it to amazon so what i have now is i have a display port splitter and a usb switch switcher and so i have to press two buttons which is kind of annoying but if you do it right you can actually press both at the same time but basically i press one button and it switches over to my laptop display port press a different button and my laptop now is
使用这台电脑的人。所以是的，我有一个非常相似的设置，但我基本上把它复制了一份，这是一种奢侈，对吧？我明白这并不是对每个人都可行，但它对我有效，我真的很喜欢它。是的，我想这引出了我们的倒数第二个话题，即处理干扰。我想我们已经谈过一点关于家庭干扰的问题。我想回顾一下，我认为被干扰，或者换种说法，就是穿插个人事务和工作事务，一定程度上可能没问题，甚至可能比去办公室却无法做任何那些事情更有效率。
controlling the mouse and keyboard and webcam and all that um and then when i want to go back i press the buttons again um and so i found that to be pretty useful because you can get one nice ergonomic setup and use it for both things i mean i i guess it's gonna depend situation. I did have a setup very, very similar to what you're describing for a while. Actually, like almost identical. But my current one, I just have two identical desks side by side. And so my gaming and like sort of family PC is like on the same desk, same chair, not the same monitor.
但再说一次，在我看来，这真的在于衡量所有这些。现在，有些事情确实会让人分心，比如如果你有一只狗一直打扰你之类的，那是真正的干扰。但我认为大多数时候，我们只是被家里需要做的事情所困扰，这些事情太显眼了。比如，甚至只是简单的事情，比如“哦，垃圾满了”。我现在看到的次数比以前多三四倍。所以你往往会花大量时间在这些事情上。是的，我认为像收快递，待在那里，这是一种……
My work monitor is a little bigger, a little nicer. And I have a laptop stand that I actually have my ipad on which is what i use for video conferencing um so it's like a custom you know built device doesn't matter what i'm compiling or doing in the back end my my videos run smooth um but yeah i i have two side-by-side setups that are very similar but not not identical um i use a split keyboard split mechanical keyboard um versus the the regular desktop is a conjoined one because not everybody has gone through you know the just the the sitting there for the same length of time and making sure to figure out the right finger habits and stuff so other people use that computer i'm the only one
我的工作显示器稍微大一点，稍微好一点。我有一个笔记本电脑支架，我实际上把iPad放在上面，这就是我用于视频会议的设备，所以它是一个定制的设备，无论我在后台编译或做什么，我的视频运行都很流畅。但是的，我有两套并排的设置，它们非常相似，但不完全相同。我使用分体式键盘，分体式机械键盘，而普通的台式机是一个连接在一起的键盘，因为不是每个人都经历过，你知道，只是坐在那里同样长的时间，并确保找出正确的指法习惯之类的，所以其他人使用那台电脑，我是唯一一个
who uses this computer um and so yeah i i have a very similar setup but i have it basically duplicated and that's a luxury right like i i understand that's not possible for everyone but it works for me and i really like it yeah um i guess that kind of goes into our second to last topic which is uh you know handling distractions i think we talked a little bit about this uh with with family distractions um i think i mean just to to recap i think being distracted or like maybe in other ways saying it is kind of like you know in you know interleaving you know personal stuff and work stuff some amount of that is probably fine like probably you know even more productive than going into the office and not being able to do any of those
使用这台电脑的人。所以是的，我有一个非常相似的设置，但我基本上把它复制了一份，这是一种奢侈，对吧？我知道这并不适合每个人，但它对我来说很有效，我真的很喜欢它。是的，我想这引出了我们的倒数第二个话题，也就是，你知道，处理干扰。我想我们谈论了一点关于这个的话题，关于家庭干扰。我想，我的意思是，回顾一下，我认为分心，或者也许用其他方式说，有点像，你知道，交替处理个人事务和工作事务。一定程度的这种做法可能没问题，可能比去办公室却什么都做不了更有效率，
things but again it's just really in my opinion it's really about measuring measuring all of that now there are some things that are truly distracting like if you have a dog uh that keeps bothering you or something like that um that's a true distraction but i think most of the most of the time it's really just we're conflicted with things that we need to do in a around the house that are just so much more apparent you know like um like even just simple things like oh a trash is trash is full. I see it now three, four times more than I did before. And so you have a tendency to just spend a ton of time on these things. Yeah. And I think like getting deliveries to the door, you know, being there kind of is an
但同样，在我看来，这真的在于衡量所有这些。现在，有些事情确实会让人分心，比如如果你有一只狗，它一直打扰你之类的，那是一个真正的干扰。但我认为大多数时候，这真的只是我们被家里需要做的事情所困扰，这些事情太明显了，你知道，比如，甚至只是简单的事情，比如，哦，垃圾桶满了。我现在看到的次数比以前多了三四倍。所以你往往会花大量时间在这些事情上。是的。而且我认为，比如快递送到门口，你知道，在那里待着也是一种
advantage of being home. And I tell people sometimes before there was any work from home and, you know, my company didn't have a hybrid. So even people who are in the office or still have some days that they're they're home um i it's very like there's so much expectation of like getting deliveries or purchases or whatever like people want you to be home and then they don't necessarily keep the hours they're supposed to be there um i had a repair person come the other day they were like six hours late and i had called several times like to try to figure out where they were they got upset like i'm gonna be there and i'm like
在家办公的优势。我告诉人们，在远程办公普及之前，我的公司没有混合办公模式。所以即使是那些在办公室工作的人，也总会有几天是在家里的。人们对你有很多期望，比如收快递、买东西等等，大家都希望你在家，但他们自己却不一定能遵守约定的时间。前几天有个维修工来，迟到了六个小时，我打了几次电话想确认他在哪，结果他反而不高兴了，说他会到的，我就想说
but if i wasn't gonna be home all day like this is gonna be ridiculous and i slotted time for you to be here and then like you're not here um yeah and so i think absolutely you're right i think having careful diligence about like what happens what what are you going to handle because come on like some stuff just needs to be handled right like some part of your house on fire or something you probably should take care of it um you know that meat has to get tended to it's got to be delicious yeah i mean that jet ski is not going to drive itself listen listen no i'm just kidding but you're right things like the dogs children like so you know my kids are uh you're right. Things like the dogs, children, like, so, you know, my kids are,
如果我不能整天待在家里，那这太荒谬了，我专门为你预留了时间，结果你却没来。是的，所以我认为你是对的，对于要处理的事情必须保持谨慎和勤勉，因为有些事情确实需要处理，比如家里着火了，你肯定得去处理。你知道，那块肉必须得照看好，它得做得美味才行。没错，那辆摩托艇可不会自己开。听着，我开玩笑的，但你是对的，像照顾狗、孩子这些事情，你知道，我的孩子们是
you know, kind of middle school age during the summer, they're home. That's not fair to others for me to, you know, change or behave differently, right? Like when they're home, that's how I kind of view it. So I have to set up a way to interact with them where, you know, like, hey, I can be here. I'm here to help you. But like, you also you also you know can't like these times are times where i'm doing focus and so i think absolutely right like distractions and people especially if you're if in a an asymmetric thing if everybody's work from home i think everybody kind of can do the same thing and it'd be similar but i think also being cognizant if some people are in the office and you're not then like you kind of don't want this like constant awareness that you are you know doing all this random stuff and they're here trying to get your attention or be focused
你知道，他们正处于初中阶段，暑假期间都在家。如果因为他们在家，我就改变工作方式或表现得不同，这对其他人来说是不公平的，对吧？我是这么看的。所以我必须建立一种与他们互动的方式，比如，嘿，我可以待在这里，我在这里是为了帮助你们，但你们也知道，这些时间是我专注工作的时间。所以我认为你是对的，干扰因素，尤其是如果你处于一种非对称的状态，如果每个人都在家办公，我想大家都能做同样的事情，情况会类似。但我也认为，如果有些人还在办公室而你不在，你就不希望那种时刻意识到你在做各种杂事，而他们却在努力引起你的注意或保持专注。
um and so you know yeah like i said i think a lot of that can be very difficult but you got to be i think intentional about it and making sure that you don't have lots of noises you have a space that you can work from or or we didn't talk about it but i mean it was a thing before now kind of like with we work but kind of went away but shared spaces where maybe you're remote but you still go to a place that has an office and actually yeah let's for a lot of these things let's dive into that actually because i forgot actually a whole chapter in my story, which is related to that is, as I said, I wasn't crazy about working from home. I did change jobs. And actually, the biggest reason I changed jobs was that it was an in-person job um and this was a few years ago so um like around 2021 or so and um and it was a we work so there were about eight of us uh the the whole company was 1600 so this was like a tiny fraction of the company but it was enough that they could get a um an office
所以，正如我所说，我认为这很难，但你必须要有意为之，确保没有太多的噪音，拥有一个可以工作的空间。我们还没谈到这一点，但在现在这种模式之前，WeWork 曾经很流行，虽然现在没那么火了，但共享办公空间也是一种选择，也许你是远程办公，但你仍然去一个有办公室的地方。实际上，让我们深入探讨一下，因为我刚才忘了故事里的一个章节，这与此相关。如我所说，我并不热衷于在家办公。我换了工作，其实我换工作最大的原因就是那是一份需要到岗的工作。那是几年前，大概是2021年左右，那是一个 WeWork 办公点，我们大概有八个人，整个公司有1600人，所以这只是公司的一小部分，但足以让他们租下一个办公室。
and so it started off as eight i think it grew to around like 12 or 13 people obviously it's all sorts of random people at the company so it's not like i had a whole team there or anything like that um but the we work thing was was was interesting you know it it's sort of a good middle ground where you know you don't have like a shared space you know it's like uh uh when you go to the water cooler there's people for all sorts of different companies you have a kind of like your one room that you have to lock you can't you don't really know the people in the other rooms at least not in the beginning so you can't really trust them so it is kind of like a weird situation i would say um i don't think it's uncanny valley territory you know like i don't think it's actually worse than being at
起初是八个人，后来增长到12或13人左右。显然，公司里各种各样的人都有，所以并不是说我有一个完整的团队在那里。但 WeWork 的体验很有趣，它算是一个很好的中间地带。你没有一个共享空间，当你去茶水间时，你会遇到来自各种不同公司的人。你有属于自己的、可以上锁的房间，至少在刚开始时，你并不认识其他房间的人，所以你不能真正信任他们，这确实是一个有点奇怪的情况。我不认为这属于恐怖谷效应，也不认为它比待在
home or being in the office uh uh you know it's not like something that's like strictly worse than both of those um but it is somewhere kind of in the middle where it is not quite that office feeling, but you do get some of it. And I like, too, that you get the commute. And it's also close to, at least in my case, that WeWork was close to downtown. So I'd have a lot of different events in the evening where I could leave my car parked at the office and then go and hear someone talk about uh you know golang or something um and uh so so I think it checked a lot of those boxes um uh and then just I guess to finish off the story the company I was at got acquired and the the parent company that acquired us shut down all the we works which was kind of personally
家里或办公室更糟。它不是那种比两者都差的情况，但它确实处于中间地带，虽然没有那种纯粹的办公室感觉，但你确实能感受到一些。我也喜欢它带来的通勤感。而且，至少在我的情况下，那个 WeWork 离市中心很近。所以我晚上会有很多不同的活动，我可以把车停在办公室，然后去听别人讲关于 Go 语言之类的东西。所以我认为它满足了很多需求。最后把故事讲完，我所在的公司被收购了，收购我们的母公司关闭了所有的 WeWork，这让我个人
kind of a bummer uh but i understand why they did it um but oh yeah so getting back to your point the we works are are pretty nice and you know if you do uh feel like you want to go in an office and you have a small coalition of people at your company who feel the same way and are close enough together, you can recommend a WeWork. I basically did the whole thing in a sense like I found the WeWork. We dealt with all the pricing. I ordered the monitors for everybody. So I basically did the whole thing from scratch
感到有点遗憾，但我理解他们为什么要这么做。回到你的观点，WeWork 确实很不错。如果你确实想去办公室，而且公司里有一小群志同道合的人，并且住得足够近，你可以推荐 WeWork。从某种意义上说，我基本上包办了整个过程，我找到了 WeWork，处理了所有定价问题，还为每个人订购了显示器。所以我基本上是从零开始完成了这一切。
and actually ended up not being as expensive as i thought it would be um you know for a company it was very reasonable um so so yeah something to consider do you think it's something that an individual could do like if they're just in this place by themselves can they just like rent a space there yeah a person on my team at my last job did that they got a we work for themselves um i know this because they asked me if we could reimburse them and i tried and we couldn't but so i'm sorry about that if you're listening i tried my hardest but um but but uh they end up paying out of pocket it was actually pretty reasonable um i don't remember the number also they're in new jersey so i'm sure it's it would yeah it would vary wildly but um but yeah i do know people who have done that and um um you know
结果发现并没有我想象的那么贵，对于一家公司来说，价格非常合理。所以，这确实值得考虑。你认为个人可以这样做吗？如果他们只是独自一人，他们可以租一个空间吗？是的，我上一份工作团队里有人这样做过，他们为自己租了一个 WeWork。我知道这一点是因为他们问我是否可以报销，我尝试过但没能成功，所以如果你在听的话，我很抱歉，我已经尽力了。但他们最终自掏腰包，其实价格相当合理。我不记得具体数字了，而且他们在纽泽西州，所以我肯定价格会有很大差异，但我确实认识这样做过的人。
especially like in his case i think he has two kids who are under four i think and so he's like i just can't be it's just it's just yelling all the time at home so use it an apartment so um so i think it made a ton of sense for him and yeah i'd recommend that as a thing folks can can try out there's a bit of a wide-ranging uh bit of tangent laden a podcast today but but i you know i think we we covered it from all aspects so it's good it's bad yeah like anything maybe like uh one last thing to cover is the future like where do you think this is going do you think rto is going to be enforced by a lot of companies you think a pendulum is going to swing back what do you think the future is going to be this is hard i mean i think like we said, this existed for a long time. So I think that there is an economic advantage, in my opinion, for companies to pursue not just the same solution.
特别是在他的情况下，我想他有两个四岁以下的孩子，所以他觉得家里总是吵吵闹闹的，所以他租了一个空间。我认为这对他来说非常有意义，我也会推荐大家尝试一下。今天这期播客内容比较广泛，涉及了很多题外话，但我认为我们从各个方面都涵盖到了，有好有坏。最后再讨论一件事，关于未来。你认为未来会怎样？你认为很多公司会强制要求重返办公室吗？你认为钟摆会摆回去吗？你觉得未来会是什么样？这很难说。我的意思是，正如我们所说，这种情况已经存在很长时间了。所以我认为，在我看来，公司追求不仅仅是同一种解决方案是有经济优势的。
I think there's comfort in sort of doing the same thing as all your other industry peers. But I mean, I think there's economic advantage to companies who are willing to do things different and try different things and offer stuff that's off normal. Or for very large companies, it doesn't even have to be the whole company has one policy, right? Like, I think that's an advantage of big companies. And so I think we will see more variants. I think we'll see a lot of struggles with companies changing. And I think not all the time, but sometimes companies change policies. And this has been true before and it's true now around remote offices and remote work. I think famously, you and I worked at a place that changed how many remote offices they wanted to have. And this was a big thing. And is that part of the economic cycle?
我认为做和行业内其他同行一样的事情会让人感到安心。但我的意思是，我认为对于那些愿意尝试不同做法、提供非常规选择的公司来说，是有经济优势的。或者对于非常大的公司来说，甚至不需要全公司执行同一项政策，对吧？我认为这是大公司的优势。所以我认为我们会看到更多的变体。我认为我们会看到很多公司在变革中挣扎。我认为并非总是如此，但有时公司会改变政策。这在远程办公普及之前和现在都是一样的。我想你和我曾经工作过的地方就改变了他们想要的远程办公点数量，这是一件大事。这是经济周期的一部分吗？
Is it part of trying to reduce headcount, save expenses, consolidation, tactical? It's very difficult to disentangle these things because even if people say why they're doing something, always say it. So I think you'll continue to see ebb and flow and people pointing at reductionist views of why that happened. But I think we'll see more variants i think as video technology gets you know just more accepted and more reliable percentage of people who do remote work you know let's call it at least two days a week or more probably going to continue to be pretty high, but we'll probably stabilize for a while until we see some other change that drives it differently or an innovative, really big
这是为了裁员、节省开支、整合或战术调整的一部分吗？很难理清这些事情，因为即使人们说出他们做某事的原因，也总是那样说。所以我认为你会继续看到起伏，人们会指出导致这种情况的简化观点。但我认为我们会看到更多的变体。我认为随着视频技术变得更加被接受和可靠，远程办公（比如每周至少两天或更多）的人数比例可能会继续保持相当高，但可能会在一段时间内趋于稳定，直到我们看到其他驱动变革的因素，或者一家具有创新性的、非常大的
up-and-coming company that people try to fight against really shows a different way forward, I guess. So I think we'll probably be stable roughly where we are for a while. And I think it kind of makes sense. I think the belief that some people do it, but for the most part, not like everybody's going to be van dwellers and we're all going to like be in a van and travel around like it's remote work, but it's nomadic, you know, virtual nomad, you know, van dwelling, like whatever that you see these things from time to time. Like, oh, I worked from Southeast Asia and I worked from the ski resort in the winter. And I were, and for all the reasons we just said, I actually don't think that's
新兴公司展现出一种不同的前进道路。所以我认为我们可能会在一段时间内保持大致稳定。我认为这在某种程度上是有道理的。我认为那种认为有些人会这样做，但大多数人不会的想法是正确的，并不是每个人都会成为“厢式货车居住者”，我们不会都住在货车里到处旅行。虽然是远程办公，但它是游牧式的，你知道，虚拟游牧，厢式货车居住，无论你时不时看到这些东西。比如，哦，我在东南亚工作，我在冬天的滑雪胜地工作。基于我们刚才说的所有原因，我其实不认为那是
anything except a vanishingly small minority of people because- Yeah. I was talking to somebody who did this for five years and they got actually really burnt out of being a nomad. And so, yeah, I agree. I don't think it's sustainable. I think all the distractions around getting a reliable internet connection around, you know, maybe if you run your own business, I mean, there's always exceptions, right?
除了极少数人之外的普遍现象。是的。我曾和一位这样做过五年的人交谈，他们实际上对这种游牧生活感到非常疲惫。所以，是的，我同意。我不认为这是可持续的。我认为围绕获得可靠的网络连接，以及如果你经营自己的企业，总是会有例外，对吧？
But the distractions, if you have a family, if whatever, like it's just, even I talk to people, you know, because I'm remote or like the place I work offers remote weeks. People are like, oh, I'm going to take this while we go on a family vacation to Europe. And it's like, okay, so all your family is going to be like doing cool things in Europe because, you know, we're in the United States and they're going to travel to Europe, going to do fun vacation-y things.
但干扰因素，如果你有家庭，无论如何，这只是……即使我与人交谈，因为我是远程办公，或者我工作的地方提供远程办公周。人们会说，哦，我要在去欧洲家庭度假时利用这段时间。这就像是，好吧，所以你的家人都要在欧洲做很酷的事情，因为我们在美国，他们要去欧洲旅行，做有趣的度假活动。
And you're just going to sit and work in the hotel in a much worse than normal place to be working, cramped, bad internet, you know, whatever. And like, you think that's going to actually be productive. Uh, and most people kind of agree, they realize it. And so it, it's very rare that someone does that. Yep. Yep. Totally agree. It's, it's one of these things that like, it sounds cool, like until you really think about it and it's like okay do i want to work for five days in this like cramped hotel room just so that like i could ski you know saturday and sunday and maybe wednesday evening or do i want to work in like a very ergonomic friendly place where it's quiet
而你只是坐在酒店里，在一个比平时工作环境差得多的地方工作，空间狭窄，网络糟糕，等等。你认为这真的能提高效率吗？大多数人都同意，他们意识到了这一点。所以很少有人会这样做。是的，完全同意。这就像是，听起来很酷，直到你真正思考它，你会想，我真的想在这个狭窄的酒店房间里工作五天，只是为了能在周六、周日甚至周三晚上滑雪吗？还是我想在一个符合人体工程学、安静的地方工作，
and then just take two weeks off and go skiing every day like it's just the other one just doesn't make a lot of sense when you really try it out um cool yeah so i i guess i'll give my prediction i think that um i think that we'll reach some kind of you know stable equilibrium where where will be a couple of remote folks on each team. And so no team will be able to no team will be all getting together all the time. And so it's going to be kind of expected that like, hey, when there's a team
然后休两周假，每天去滑雪？当你真正尝试时，前者确实说不通。酷，是的，所以我猜我会给出我的预测。我认为我们将达到某种稳定的平衡，每个团队都会有几个远程办公的人。因此，没有团队能够一直聚在一起。所以大家会预期，当有团队
meeting, there's going to be Zoom there and there's going to be accommodations made for remote people in every team meeting. meeting, there's going to be Zoom there and there's going to be accommodations made for remote people in every team meeting. I think that's going to be the norm. I think that dam has like completely broken and there's no way, there's no reason to do anything different. I think for people managers,
会议时，会有 Zoom 接入，每个团队会议都会为远程办公的人提供便利。我认为这将成为常态。我认为那道堤坝已经完全决堤了，没有理由再做任何不同的事情。我认为对于人事经理来说，
that's where I could see companies companies continuing to draw a firm line. And so it could get to the point where you say, look, you could be an engineer, maybe you could be a line manager. But if you want to get that promotion to vice president, you have to move across the country. And so we might see a situation where, you know, like empty nesters, like relocate. It's like, okay, you know, I've, I raised my kids, they moved out, I'm ready to be a vice president, I have to move to the headquarters. And so kids go to college and you end up going to headquarters of, you know, company X or whatever it is. Because that seems like where they're going. Although there was that notable case for the Starbucks CEO, I guess, doesn't live in Seattle. And there's like a big hoopla about that. So yeah, I do think that for certain roles,
那是公司可能继续划定明确界限的地方。所以可能会出现这种情况，你说，看，你可以是一名工程师，也许你可以是一名部门经理。但如果你想获得副总裁的晋升，你就必须搬到全国的另一边。所以我们可能会看到这种情况，比如空巢老人搬迁。就像是，好吧，我抚养大了我的孩子，他们搬走了，我准备好成为副总裁了，我必须搬到总部。所以孩子们去上大学，你最终去了 X 公司的总部。因为这似乎是他们的发展方向。尽管星巴克首席执行官有一个著名的案例，他不住在西雅图，这引起了很大的轰动。所以是的，我确实认为对于某些角色，
and obviously Patrick talked about manufacturing and things like you just literally can't do remote but but of the roles that are um you know entire that can be done remote there's going to be a certain set of those roles where there's just continuing to be pressure to be in the office i actually find that research is one of these roles ironically there's this feeling that oh if you're a team of researchers that you have to be around the whiteboard together which i think is actually completely wrong i think actually as someone who worked in research for many many years i think research should be like one of the first things that you distribute um but uh but we'll have to see how that plays out i think there's still a lot of unknowns but i think we both agree that remote work is not going away.
显然帕特里克谈到了制造业等领域，你确实无法远程办公，但在那些可以完全远程完成的角色中，会有一些角色仍然面临着必须在办公室工作的压力。我实际上发现研究工作就是其中之一，具有讽刺意味的是，人们有一种感觉，哦，如果你是一个研究团队，你们必须聚在白板前，我认为这完全是错误的。作为一名在研究领域工作多年的人，我认为研究应该是最先被分配的任务之一。但我们还得看看情况如何发展，我认为还有很多未知数，但我认为我们都同意远程办公不会消失。
And I think that people should feel comfortable moving to, and I'm just going to pick, no offense to Idaho, but moving to Idaho and being able to get a tech job remotely. I think that people should feel confident. If you're wondering whether to make that move to Idaho, if you're still going to be able to have a job, I think you can make that move to Idaho. I don't know the internet quality in Idaho. That used to be a big concern. Now you just use taking it full circle.
我认为人们应该感到舒适地搬到——我随便选一个，对爱达荷州没有冒犯之意——搬到爱达荷州，并且能够远程获得一份科技工作。我认为人们应该感到自信。如果你在考虑是否要搬到爱达荷州，如果你仍然能够拥有一份工作，我认为你可以搬到爱达荷州。我不知道爱达荷州的互联网质量如何。那曾经是一个很大的担忧。现在你只需要使用它，一切又回到了原点。
You use Starlink. Yeah, that's right. Yeah. You just catch the internet on chopsticks. Cool. All right, folks. Another awesome episode episode thank you so much for listening um thanks so much for supporting us on patreon um a lot of fun there and we will catch you all next time Thank you. Share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你使用 Starlink。是的，没错。你只需要用筷子就能连上网。酷。好了，伙计们。又一期精彩的节目，非常感谢大家的收听，感谢大家在 Patreon 上对我们的支持，那里有很多乐趣，我们下次再见。谢谢。分享并保持一致。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。